this is jocko podcast number three oh
eight with echo charles and me
jacqueline good evening echo good
evening so tonight
at long last we are going to
wrap up what has ended up being a
six six-part series
i got a little out of control didn't i
well i kind of i kind of got a little
out of control on this one well how not
to do it cannot be overstated how not to
do it cannot be overstated explain that
means like
if there are little tips how not to do
something let's face it that the value
is what i call infinite it's infinite
check good point the book is called on
the psychology of military incompetence
we started on 303 podcast 303 304 305
306 307 that's a lot of podcast this is
the this is the winner
most number of podcasts on a single book
if you haven't listened those you can go
back i can i actually will say this in
preparing this one if you haven't
listened those you don't even have to go
back you can listen to this one there
might be a couple references
but they're not super
you'll be able to get through them
and this this section that we're about
to cover kind of starts with the crux of
the book but again
when i started reading this book a
couple of years ago it was a couple
maybe it was a year ago maybe a couple
years ago
actually i forget when when i got this
book but
i knew it was going to take a while i
don't know it's going to take this long
but here we are
um i apologize for taking so long
uh
like you said though there's
when you understand how not to do
something and you understand what the
pitfalls are and the mistakes you can
make and
the traps these things are all traps
they're all traps and when you start to
be able to see the traps it's
it helps a person
a lot it doesn't make them not going to
the traps that's the whole point that's
one of the whole points of this book is
people know
that this is a trap and they walk right
into it they just can't even help
themselves like remember the whole name
dropping thing that he talked about
i forget which one it was but name
dropping everybody knows it looks wack
and they still do it they can't control
themselves
well let me rephrase that an arrogant
egotistical
person that's nervous about how they
look they're gonna name drop even though
they know it looks bad even though
they'll point at someone else and say oh
listen to carrie name drop
they'll do that and then they'll name
them yeah they'll go hey i see uh carrie
was name dropping over here did you see
him name dropping me i was talking to
joe rogan the other day
you know what i'm saying
that's how whack people are yes that's
that's how we get stuck in lame
situations yeah
so
the crux of this book is actually the
chapter that we're going to start with
right now dave burke couldn't make it by
the way good deal dude working busy
um the the chapter
here is called authoritarianism
and this is kind of the crux and this is
this is what we need to watch out for
well this is this is what we need to
watch out for this authoritarian mindset
look do you need to watch out for it as
a nation yes you better especially as
things start getting imposed on your on
your life
because that slides into
authoritarianism
and that's that's a slippery slope and i
know you that you're going to bring up
the slippery slope fallacy
well i see it in your eyes
well again and i'll say that i said it
before where there is such thing as a
slippery slope and there is such thing
as a slippery slope fallacy they're not
like one doesn't you know they both
exist they both exist exactly right
so authoritarianism
in our minds
we have to watch out for it
in our teams as leaders we have to watch
out for it and yes as human beings
living in a whatever country you live in
you need to watch out for that
authoritarianism because
it's a thing that once it starts to take
hold the authoritarian it snowballs yeah
like i get a little bit of control
authoritarian people when they get a
little bit of control they want more
control and then they get a little bit
more they want even more and they don't
stop
and it's a it's a
it's a psychopathology that they have
that they can't contain it
so here we go authoritarianism in
discussing military organizations it was
suggested that a symbiotic relationship
exists between certain characteristics
of armed services and the private needs
of the individual members so what that's
saying is when you go in the military
there's certain needs that certain
people have certain psychological needs
that people have
that going in the military satisfies
those needs for instance here's a here's
an example of where this is a bad thing
i like to rule over people
i know if i become an officer in the
military i'll be able to rule over those
privates
so it sort of
satisfies
that to me
so there's a nice relationship i have i
want to be an authoritarian this puts me
in an authoritarian position i love it
is this true of all military people no
it's not continuing on emphasis was laid
upon the central role in this
relationship of anxiety that insidious
motivator of such of much human behavior
in the military mind it was pointed out
anxiety has many sources fear of death
and mutilation fear of suppression
fear of failure and social disapproval
fear of public disgrace and underlying
all that fear of total disorder
which is inseparable product of
unleashing normally tabooed instinctual
forces so if you're a person that
doesn't like disorder
you look at the military and go on
that looks pretty good you got to go to
bed at a certain time all these people
will listen to me we get to follow
orders they're going to tell me what to
do everyone's going to listen to when i
tell them what to do
that's you you're if you don't like
disorder that's a great place to be
until what happens
the layer of total disorder on planet
earth
opens its jaws and that is combat so now
you're a person that doesn't like
disorder and for your job at the moment
of truth you are thrust into the jaws of
the highest level of disorder in the
world that is combat
and that's why this is that's what this
book is about this psychology of
military incompetence is because people
that like order and join the military
because they like order and then their
actual job look part of their job is
marching around a parade field and
inspecting uniforms and keeping
everything squared away that's great but
the when that when that homie shows up
and shits getting crazy
they lose their minds
so when you're looking when you're
judging and you're thinking oh what if
that bad guy be a good military officer
they're highly disciplined
they're highly disciplined they they
they follow orders they're authoritarian
they seem like they'd be great you need
to remember what's that person gonna do
when things get wild and they're gonna
get wild
continuing on finally it was suggested
and you can see where this whole book
that little that
that crux that's why i said this is the
crux of the book that crux right there
is why this is so fascinating to me
because i've seen this throughout my
career
people that were squared away people
that were
highly disciplined people that were
loved for things to be in order
and when things weren't going right or
things were getting wild they'd lose
their minds
and by the way if they never got put
into a situation where things got wild
they get promoted by the way they're
getting promoted because they're the
most
ordered they kept the tightest reigns on
their troops
back to the book finally it was
suggested that a special predisposition
toward these several sorts of anxiety
may be present some people as a result
of their early childhood again this is
where and somebody pointed this out to
me on one of the youtube comments the
word i was looking for was psychobabble
psychobabble because again this guy was
a psychologist so he ties all this stuff
into weird freudian freaking childhood
experiences and i can't back any of that
up i don't know about any of that what i
do know is this
people have different personalities
where those personalities came from i
don't really know and i actually don't
care you show up to a seal team your
personality is that whatever whatever
your personality is and
that's that's great that's fine
i don't care where it came from if
you're hyper ordered and you can't stand
it when things get wild you're not going
to be a good seal officer
or a good seal leader
if you're totally
rebellious and you can't fall into line
ever well that's too far in the other
direction and now you can't control
anything you can't control yourself so
we want to find something that balances
that dichotomy
but whether it comes from early
childhood and the way you were potty
trained and all this kind of
psychobabble i don't know
i don't know we'll have to ask uh jordan
b peterson name drop about that one yes
sir
such people may well be drawn towards
military organizations because the
latter have of necessity
perfected devices like [__] and
discipline and hierarchical command
structures and rigid conventions which
not only allow aggression without
anxiety but also reduce anxiety that may
have originated much earlier period of
life okay
again a little bit a little bit
psychoanalysis too much for me it's sort
of it's a bummer because
as i've said many times jordan peterson
made me start to like think maybe
psychology was sort of a real thing this
is kind of drawing back into the
direction
oh sorry psychologist somebody somebody
went i was reading youtube
uh notes no comments
and somebody was telling me that
you know what much of what freud said
was actually right but he's just been so
uh
like hammered by his reputation because
he was a cocaine
fiend
and that now we kind of dis
disperse or dispatch everything that he
said so maybe i was a little hard on him
i don't know as far as i'm concerned if
you're doing a lot of cocaine like that
and you're prescribing it to a bunch of
people and you're lying about who's
getting cured i kind of take a lot of
what you said and throw it out the
window oh yeah well
what what's the there's a there's a
that's a bias too right the
uh cocaine addictive addiction
yes that's my bias i'm biased against
people that are addicted to cocaine no
it's not sorry it's not a bias it's a
logical fallacy i don't know if you're
you're committing this logical fallacy
but it's um it's the
i forget what it is but the example is
like oh
why would you listen to fred fred
doesn't even have a job
so it's kind of like
okay it's like i think i am committing
almost like i'm kind of like why would
you listen to freud i know freud's
addicted to cocaine yeah hey look i'm
lying to people i'm not saying you're
making the bad bad decision or nothing
like that i'm saying from a logical
standpoint it's technically a fallacy
it's like okay that means if you do
cocaine everything else you say is
incorrect okay is that what that means
from a logical standpoint you're right
okay
well i'll concede that per well that's
that's what i am conceding
freud was right part of the time give
freud on some of the stuff
as he was snorting
in light of all this it is encouraging
to encounter a substantial body of
research which not only provides support
for the thesis but also fills in many of
the gaps
it is that on the authoritarian
personality and then they get into this
massive section about the authoritarian
personality which i'm not called for the
whole thing because i've already spent
six freaking podcasts on this book which
is all good but i'm gonna do a little
bit of it for the impetus behind the
study of authoritarianism we have to
thank the founders and proponent and
proponents of the third reich
they
it who was presented
to the world a phenomenon the like of
which has never been seen before since
the systematic bureaucratized
murder of six million jews to the
inquiring mind anti-semitism on this
scale would seem to demand at the very
least some explanation for a group of
researchers at frankfurt
and later at berkeley california the
fact that human prejudice could assume
such monstrous proportions suggested the
possibility of a particular personality
type being implicated in the
perpetration of these dark events so
basically he's saying look the nazis
were
psycho
where did their personality come from
what type of people had that personality
and then he goes into a nazi
psychologist
whose name was jinch something like that
jinx i don't know sorry they're you nazi
bastard from mispronouncing your name so
he broke it down and there was s types
which
s-types
at the at the high end could have
something called synesthesia have you
ever heard of synesthesia before
synesthesia this is a very interesting
story so
synthesia seth stone
he
was could memorize any number
immediately so if he met like a female
in a bar
he would say what's your number and they
would say it
and he would immediately know it hell
yeah and then he was really good at
weird math problems
and and he could memorize dates
and
one day we were talking because it was
it was enough
it was noticeable enough how good he was
at it
that
you think to yourself there's something
a little different that's really weird
how he could memorize this stuff
so
he said to me one day he goes you know
this is kind of weird but
when i
see numbers i don't see a number i see a
color
and and it has like a texture to it yeah
and i was like okay bro
i mean if we weren't in the military i
think you were maybe on some
lsd or whatever
so he i said what do you mean he says
well for me and he then he described the
colors of each the colors and textures
of each
number
so
the only ones i remember was that zero
was like hollow he said he said zero is
hollow it's not it's like it's not there
uh
one
was white
and the other one i remember is
seven
was yellow and the reason i remember
that one is because i have two sevens in
my phone number and when the first time
i asked him what my i said say my phone
number in colors and he was like you
know yellow yellow hollow but blue
yellow yellow and i have two sevens and
i said what's i got seven yellow because
yeah
so it was just weird he had no idea why
this was the situation huh that's crazy
so
one day i'm in a bookstore
and this is you know kind of murdering a
day when you wouldn't just go on a
website to buy your books i'm in a
bookstore and i see
numbers
on a cover of a book
and they're all colored and textured
and i was i was that's weird and i walk
over and pick it up and i start looking
through it and it says oh this book is
about a person that had
synesthesia
and so it so i look it up
synesthesia is a thing where you have
multiple
multiple modes of
of
interpreting information yeah
so for instance numbers have colors
they can have
um
letters can have colors but that's so
that's the way
that's the way seth
fought yeah
and so for this nazi
jench
that was kind of the far end of this
kind of wild creative
thing this kind of wild creative person
here it says to have subjective
experiences in one modality when
receiving stimulation another this is
the kind of wildest brain that you can
get and so this nazi guy
this is the s type these are people that
are s types
it doesn't mean they necessarily have
synesthesia but they're leaning in that
direction and this quote has the liberal
in his views eccentric behavior also
weak effeminate and prone to heretical
belief that people are largely shaped by
their enviro environment and education
again this is from a nazi psychologist
which i mean if we're not listening to
freud we're certainly not listening to
this nazi dude
so but he's he's breaking it down into
two types the s-type and then the other
type is the j-type
and according to this guy
um
the j-type
were
quote good types
that would make good nazis amongst their
sterling qualities were purity and
perception and the sure knowledge that
human behavior is determined by blood
soil and national tradition
hence freaking nazis
the j type so the nazi type would be a
he-man hard and tough a man you could
rely on
these qualities would he said have been
handed down by a long line of north
german ancestors
this is what the nazi says and it's just
it's kind of funny because
uh well cestone was about as hard of a
bastard as you could ever know and uh
certainly a he-man individual as well
and a warrior a big freaking viking
warrior texted his mom the other day i
was like yup thanks for letting me hang
out with that freaking savage viking kid
of yours
um
so now we go to
the berkeley study so so we just did the
nazi study who got these two different
types the s-type which is sort of the
liberal sort of effeminate type and then
the the j-type which is more of the
conservative hardcore type
then the american researchers
later uh
going back to book also found two
contrasting personality types and these
were very like those described by change
needless to say they evaluated them
rather differently the one that
corresponded the j type they called the
authoritarian personality
such a person was anti-semitic rigid
intolerant of ambiguity again think
about this if you're intolerant of
ambiguity think of how you're going to
perform in combat you're going to be
great in the military in the in the in
the rear of the military because you're
you don't like ambiguity as soon as
you're in combat you don't exactly know
what's happening you gotta make a
decision you're gonna hate it
so
um
intolerant of ambiguity and hostile to
people or groups racially different from
himself
by the same token the polar opposite to
this type change
contemptible anti-type was
individualistic
tolerant democratic
unprejudiced and egalitarian
so you got these two different
personalities
the nazis called the bad one good
and the berkeley people called the good
one bad so you get however you want to
break that down
uh their test provided measures of
anti-semitism ethnocentrism political
and economic conservatism and implicit
anti-democratic trends or potentiality
for fascism which they called the f
scale like what is your potential of
becoming a fascist
this much of which is based on by actual
utterances by the nazis measured an
individual's predisposition towards so
this is what the f-type if you have a
tendency where you could become a
fascist conventionalism
i.e rigid adherence to conventional
middle-class values
authoritarian submission
a submissive uncritical attitude toward
the idealized moral authorities of the
group which he identifies himself and
that's what's kind of crazy right you
would think that authoritarians would be
you'd be hard to control but if you're
part of their if they're part of that
group they're in the game yeah you know
so that's why like the young
the young officer in the military that
he's totally down he's he's saluting
with utmost vigor because he's part of
that system and he just he's on board
he's submissive to the system
authoritarian aggression i.e a tendency
to be on the lookout for and to condemn
reject and punish people who violate
conventional values
it's kind of weird how there's like
right now
you've got
antifa who's supposed to be sort of like
the wild anti-fascist who's actually
totally on board with what i'm saying
right now as they're they're off the
charts on the f scale yeah so like this
i don't know if this s f scale would
reflect this
specifically or or accurately but
essentially you have like two two sides
right one one is real conventional right
they're probably probably i don't know
but they're probably gonna ignore
exceptions you know the value of
exceptions and nuance and all this stuff
right they're gonna tend to ignore it
right then you have the other side who
probably
over value nuance and exceptions kind of
like hey if there's these exceptions oh
that must be just as equal as the rule
because you know you kind of look at the
individual you know
so
that that antifa analogy is absolutely
correct they're doing the exact same
thing they just reversed it
yeah you gotta you gotta kind of i don't
know back in the day it seems seems like
everyone was way more just in the middle
well balance is what we've what we lose
and what you want even on these two
things
do you want to be a fascist no but do
you want to be um crazy uncontrollable
no you want to be balanced
yeah and even even just valuing like the
the group
and then on the other on the other hand
valuing the individual it's like you got
to value both of those things
yeah 100
um
next one anti-interception
i.e
opposition to the subjective the
imaginative and the tender minded
superstition
and stereotype
power and toughness preoccupation with
the dominant submission strong weak
leader follower dimension identification
with power figures over emphasis on
conventional attributes of the ego
exaggeration exaggerated exaggerated
assertion of strength and toughness
so how much of that is important like
you know that's putting you out there on
that scale a little bit i'm starting to
drift man starting to drift
destructiveness and cynicism
generalized hostility vilification of
the human okay so
you know obviously with their a lot of
this was focused around hey the nazis
and where the nazis came from part of
that f thing is they can look at humans
and be like whatever they don't matter
projectivity
the belief that wild and dangerous
things go on in the world the projection
outwards of unconscious emotional
impulses
puritanical an exaggerated concern with
sexuals goings on
so you got these two personality types
another little note here these torturous
machinations of the authority of the
authoritarian mind ramify yet further
because he has to deny his own
shortcomings he dare not look inward
he is fearful of insight and strenuously
avoids questioning his own motives
again
this is when people are they're not real
confident with themselves so they
project and look at everyone else
similarly the authoritarian personality
is intolerant of ambivalence and
ambiguity we already hit that just as he
cannot harbor negative and positive
feelings for the same person
but must dichotomize reality into loved
people versus hated people
so that's very that's a very uh
that's restating what you said
because
someone what should you be able to do
you should be able to look at echo and
be like you know what i like that echo's
you know he's he's pretty nice but also
he can get a little bit lazy sometimes
but overall
you know we're good
cryptic
messages whatever not so correct right
but for me to say
echo's nice freaking he's lazy i can't
stand them right and then you can start
looking from one individual to look to a
whole group of people as you said and i
start looking at a group of people
and just saying well that group of
people is bad
did i just do that with antifa i just
kind of start you implied it implies
yeah sorry antifa i need to be a little
bit more uh open-minded to your
individuals
yeah they're they're one of those groups
that that their for their current public
facing persona not that high
yeah
there's another
nine year research that took place
published a decade after the berkeley
research
and this is something that i've been
focused on a lot and it's
the open and closed mind
centered on the problem of an
individual's capacity to absorb fresh
information humanity it seems varies
considerably in this respect and god
that is true
so this guy his name is rok rokich
rockeach something like this and he did
the study he started breaking down the
open and closed mind some people have
open minds some people have close minds
and i actually think that this is
even
kind of trumps the f what was it the f
the f scale i think this trumps the f
scale how much can someone's mind open
how much can it close
and i've been talking a lot about this
from a leadership perspective because
it is
to me
what we have to fight all the time we
our minds are constantly trying to close
and be defensive and take care of
themselves and not allow any other ideas
in and what we have to do as people and
as leaders is constantly pull your mind
open constantly accept other people's
ideas it doesn't mean you have to think
that they're right but you have to
listen to them and assess them in an
honest way and what we have been doing
a lot of as a society is just closing
our minds to everyone else's ideas and
we don't want to hear what their
perspective is because we think we're
right
and if you do that as a leader you know
you come to me with a
viewpoint on my plan
and i don't open my mind to your
viewpoint i'm wrong yeah
um it goes on here humanity it seems
varies considerably in this respect that
the one extreme are open minds ready and
willing to entertain new facts even if
they are incompatible with their
previously held attitudes and beliefs
that's what we want you got to open your
mind hey you know what i wouldn't expect
to see those numbers or get that
feedback but there it is and i need to i
need to
put that in my calculus
the other
at the other end of the scale are closed
minds which as their names suggest
resolutely resist taking in anything
that conflicts with their preconceptions
and treasured beliefs not very
surprisingly the possession of a closed
mind turned out to be yet another aspect
of the authoritarian personality
is that
okay so you can always make like an
analogy to weightlifting for some reason
maybe you can
but i'm open to it let's hear what you
got homie but like i wonder if that's
like a lazy is you know how like by
nature like the human body and brain is
kind of late for lack of better term
it's lazy it's conserving like energy
all the time you know like so even like
lifting weights when you lift weights
your body's response to lifting weights
is just a lazy laziness mechanism and so
your body is basically saying oh shoot
that was kind of hard what do we got to
do at home in the body to make a little
bit easier next time and then it adapts
and gets bigger and stronger whatever so
it's kind of like a weird like i said
laziness lack of better term
mechanism so like when you have a closed
mind it's kind of like hey i already
learned that like don't give me some
more stuff i gotta learn
kind of thing so then it's easier like
because it's all mental it's not
physical so you just kind of resist
against it
and you can see where this ties into
everything that i have talked about from
a leadership perspective for my entire
life
which is humility because if you're
humble your mind is open if you're
arrogant your mind is closed you think
you know everything you don't need to
hear anything else you're not going to
make any adaptations yeah when you see
that little system it kind of makes
sense it makes so much sense right
especially go back to the weight lifting
like you give your body something
definitely
here bro the next day
you get that doms right you don't like
that stuff like i remember when i was
little i do some push-ups right thinking
i'm all cool or whatever do something
the next day i'm like so i didn't know
about doms that much
and bro that's a terrible feeling so
it's like bro i'm not doing that anymore
or at the very least at the in the
inside of my body my body's like hey we
got to do something easier or make it so
it's easier next time that happens so
from a mental standpoint
it makes sense where brother what do you
call it the the [__] you call you
talked about it last the cognitive
dissonance or whatever that is dom's for
your mind essentially or maybe the
precursor to i don't know it's one of
those things i'm just saying it makes
sense because that hurts you know when
you get that new stuff
i don't want that new stuff i'm good
with this old stuff closed mind yeah
he says here before leaving this section
on authoritarianism there are several
other research findings which are
pertinent to our present thesis one of
these shows the relationship between
conformity authoritarianism and the
tendency to yield to group pressures an
extreme example of this pattern is the
phenomenon per
of the participation in a lynch mob
where the naturally conformist
individual happily yields to group
pressure for the perpetration of a
criminally aggressive act which though
wholly at variance with the ethos of the
wider society accords with his own
narrow self-interest
so again
it's it's a it's a
it's counterintuitive to think that
someone that's authoritarian is going to
be more apt to go with the group
another finding concerns the effect of
authoritarianism upon problem solving in
a group situation and you know i love
this one because again i'm thinking of
it from a military perspective and you
you start thinking now you got this
authoritarian in command how are they at
problem solving well let's go to the
book
from their research
w haythorne and his colleagues concluded
this
that
equalitarian subjects i.e those low on
authoritarianism were apparently more
effective in dealing with a task and
problem than were authoritarian
so that open mind is way better for
problem solving seems obvious but
this was reflected in higher ratings of
effective intelligence leadership and
goal striving on the sorts of leaders
who emerged in the group situation they
had this to say emergent leaders in the
low f groups were more sensitive to
others
more effective leaders more prone to
making suggestions for action subject to
group sanction and less likely to give
direct orders to others this is insane
how much this matches everything i've
been talking about
a conclusion incidentally which accords
with the observation that authoritarians
are less able to appreciate the effect
they have upon others and may well think
themselves more liked and popular than
they really are
i'm chuckling as i think of my military
career and people that thought that they
were super popular and everyone hated
them
even people
attracted to a career in an
authoritarian organization
i.e the military
have been found to prefer leaders who
score low on a test of authoritarianism
presumably because authoritarians are
less sensitive to the needs of others so
even when you're
when you're kind of authoritarian
yourself and you joined the military
when you get asked about what type of
leader you like guess what you actually
like less authoritarian leaders because
they listen they treat you with respect
their minds are open
so this is the best way to lead across
the board
you know
skyscrapers here in san diego california
i'm sure it's like this ever i'm not an
engineer
you know that um
but from what i understand okay so think
of a a tall building right it's tall so
that thing better be strong right to
hold itself up
but tall buildings aren't made rigidly
they're made with a little bit of flims
flimsiness on purpose to absorb like
movement the various movements and
vibrations that may or may not come
about see what i'm saying so it's
essentially the same thing on the
surface you think oh yeah
authoritarianism that's the way you
can't destroy you destroy it it's you
can't break it or nothing like that but
by that's not how it works
if you're too rigid right you're just
going to crumble
when the wiggles start coming when the
earthquake starts coming you know again
this is why humility is the most
important aspect or characteristic for a
leader because when you're humble you're
able to move a little bit
you're able to take on new ideas you're
able to sway when the earthquake comes
and make adjustments you're not just
crumbling and falling down
it cannot be stressed too strongly that
in talking about authoritarianism we
have been discussing people towards one
end of a continuum this is important
because this is a dichotomy
this guy couldn't quite put that he
couldn't grasp that concept like your
boy right here dude
yes sir
between because you got to balance that
dichotomy but here's what he says
between this and and the other can be
found people with all shades of opinion
on the various attitudes measured the
general point is this when discussing
authoritarianism no value judgment is
intended few would dispute that in
moderation many of the traits which make
up the authoritarian personality have
value in society civilization requires
that there be some repression of sex and
aggression some exercise of discipline
and a modicum of conformity and
ordinalness
so he there's part there's aspects of
that personality which are good and
that's true in the military in fact the
military got a little bit extra
you know because you got to be a little
bit more conformised because you got to
get the t you know you got to be on
board but but it attracts people that
are too much yeah
a little bit fast forward here in other
respects however the likelihood of above
average levels of authoritarianism in
military personnel may well contribute
toward incompetence particularly when
the authoritarian has reached a level of
command where flexibility and an open
mind are
mandatory for success to be more
specific the personality traits of
authoritarianism and the associated
characteristics of the closed mind and
obsessive character may contribute to
incompetence in the following ways
one since authoritarians have been found
to be more
dishonest more irresponsible more
untrustworthy more socially conforming
more suspicious than non-authoritarians
they are unlikely to make successful
social leaders
authoritarians will be less likely to
understand enemy intentions i never
thought of that before actually here's
something new for jocko
if you're authoritarian you're less
likely to understand what the enemy's
doing because you can't even understand
their perspective yeah
and to act upon information regarding
such intentions as conflict with the
beliefs and preconceptions
which the commander might hold
that makes sense okay forgive me for all
the analogies by the way i'm just
reading this time you're talking about
the stuff buildings yeah okay so now
this time is cameras
or photographers whatever not even i'm
two for two though they were accurate
these glasses everywhere okay
amongst people all right
we'll consider a camera right or or a
photograph or whatever right you have
high resolution low resolution kind of a
situation so the authoritarianism seems
like a low resolution scenario way more
black and white way more like oh yeah
like freaking either it's this way and
if it's not this way then it's obviously
the other way
but you get a high-res photo it's like
oh that's not that's oh that's just
black obviously no no no just look
closer it's it's kind of gray it's
actually pretty dark gray and then even
within that gray there's darker and
lighter shades of
you grey colors or oh what colors what
yeah what have you this one might be
orange this one might be uh salmon
which is the color boy
eggshell
with romalin type by the way what's that
from american psycho no no but see what
i'm saying though um where
you get a low-res situation yeah yeah
they like they don't get it they don't
know and then you said well they don't
know what the enemy's thinking yeah
because they they see black yeah but the
enemy's not on black they're over here
on
88 gray yeah exactly right so yeah
that's just the way it's working see i'm
saying so you got to be well i'm not
saying you got to be i'm just saying it
might be as the book is demonstrating
more a fish effective
to have a more nuanced perception of
what's happening some higher is check
scenarios
in 1954 american research showed that
people with a high score on tests of
authoritarianism had greater difficulty
than non-authoritarians in recognizing
threatening messages when these were
presented visually
a year later another study confirmed
this finding with threatening words that
were heard instead of seen
so so someone that's authoritarian they
don't even they just don't comprehend
the world accurately that is now your
your
metaphor just became more
ample
in that right there yeah they had they
don't they can't see as well they can't
see as clear they can't see the nuance
they can't see the message yeah
three the inability to sacrifice
cherished traditions and accept
technical innovations the history of the
machine gun the tank and the aeroplane
contains striking as an evidence of this
disability
in war an ounce of calculation is worth
a ton of intuition it also saves many
lives number four the underestimation of
enemy ability
number five and he's got whole sections
about each one of these that's why you
gotta buy the book
number five an emphasis upon the
importance of blind obedience and
loyalty at the expense of initiative and
innovation
at lower levels of command so that's
just
if you lose that so if you're if you're
in charge of a company of soldiers
and your focus on is on getting them to
be blindly obedient
because you're an authoritarian it's bad
and you're and you're doing it at the
expense of having decentralized command
watch out for that
got to beware number six the protection
of the reputations of senior commanders
and punishment of those in the lower
military hierarchy if they voice any
opinion however valuable in itself
implies criticism of those higher up so
they don't want to hear any pushback on
anything
which is
again a stark contrast to what i
encourage all the time up and down the
chain of command i want push back from
my team
my team isn't pushing back actually i'm
nervous
now i think i've got blind obedience
which i don't want
number seven closely related to the
foregoing effects of authoritarianism is
an individual's propensity to blame
others for their own shortcomings
this is the opposite of extreme
ownership so the opposite of extreme
ownership is authoritarian and blaming
other people
wouldn't it suck if i was reading this
book like right now and it just wasn't
working it was all not matching up
all my theories were wrong
number eight the closed relationship
between authoritarianism and obsessive
traits has also played a significant
part in military incompetence this is a
matter which we discussed earlier
suffice it to say that the worst
excesses of bull and the clinging to
uh an acrastic ritual
have played not a not inconsiderable
part in holding back the military
machine
so when you are
hyper obsessed ocd on little things that
don't matter this is not going to help
you
number nine there's one trait of the
authoritarian personality which at first
sight may seem to have nothing to do
with military incompetence a belief in
supernatural forces
the contrary is in fact the case as a
general issue since military decision
should not be based upon a proper
weighing up of facts the introduction of
metaphysical variables into decision
making necessarily contributes noise
which decreases the probability of
decisions being correct correct concern
with what the stars foretell or hopes
and occasionally fears of the divine
intervention constitute prejudices which
can bias decisions away from realism and
towards
wishful
fantasies
that's a weird one to me because you
would think that the
people that were anti-authoritarianism
would be more kind of superstitious
but he's we didn't run through all the
examples we get all kinds of examples of
that yeah all kinds of examples through
that throughout history of people that
are authoritarian i mean hitler is a
good example because he was all into the
occult
and all that and superstitious about
stuff
one of the least number 10 one of the
least attractive aspects of the
authoritarian personality is his
generalized hostility
what the berkeley researchers called
vilification of the human this was a
trait that which was manifested to such
an extreme degree by members of the nazi
ss they commit wholesale murder not just
without guilt or shame but perhaps most
surprisingly without the slightest
evidence of revulsion
and then he says finally there is the
fact that authoritarianism
authoritarianism itself so damaging to
military endeavor will actually
predispose an individual towards
entering upon the very career wherein
his restricted personality can wreak the
most havos havoc
this is what i kind of opened up with
saying today people that have these
tendencies are attracted to the military
and he gives the following case study
case 19
cecile or cecil cecil yeah i guess
cecile would be a girl's name wouldn't
it yes sir so cecil is a male name yes
sir more of a british name we don't i've
never met an american dude named cecil
of you yes sir really yeah okay
i have not just one was he from england
no canadian no black guy cecil yeah
okay
here we go wait who's cecil peoples oh
that's a that's he's an actor
no isn't that a ufc guy
cecil people some ufc like commentator
ref maybe
i think he's a ref i'm drawing a blank
for some reason he's so peoples right
anyway cecil people shout out all right
i'm i if i
if i'm not mistaken he's a referee
early on
get get your phone and go get it right
i kind of remember him being
yeah you might be right
might have been a judge maybe he was a
judge yeah it seemed like he had some
weird background in bare-knuckle
fighting or something and then kind of
got early ufc activities going so p
evo
people see some people's is hey
there he is black guy
now we need support he's a judge why we
need to support mma judge cecil peoples
right on what from what era
um
what was his background the era that i
was watching ufc which is probably like
five years ago and before
um
so this is the guy that you claim to
know
uh i knew i worked with a guy at
american movers named
cecil
um and then there's seasonal people all
right check so here's cecil r
who's an obsessive neurotic and i wasn't
going to read this thing but i kind of
have to and i'll tell you why we get to
the end his iq was in the bright normal
range personality testing indicated that
he was very dependent on his parents but
that they were seen as being emotionally
remote and extremely demanding in
fantasy he expressed strong feelings of
aggression and anger he seemed most
interested in the history of wars and in
playing war games he shot darts with
vigor and delight in the therapist
playroom and if given a choice would
choose war games his parents said he
refused to play with other children
unless they others did exactly what they
told him what he told them to do
cecil said
when he grew up he wanted to be a
general
[Laughter]
so there you go that's the kind of
personality we don't want joining the
military but that is fired up to join
the military
next chapter 23 mothers of incompetence
we're going kind of heavy i'm not going
to go to too deep into this chapter
because it going a little bit into the
psychology world which again i think
this
some of the psychology is a little bit
outdated
this is coming from me and i'm those
psychologists
sounds like a closed mind scenario okay
we'll open it up okay good point oh man
uh yeah you caught me i'm busted for the
reader not previously versed in the
psychology of authoritarianism the
preceding chapter may have come as
something a surprise at first sight
the traits of orderliness
tough-mindedness obedience to authority
punitiveness and the rest well may have
seemed the very embodiment
of hard-hitting masculinity ideally
suited to the job of being a soldier
that is an epic statement right all
that's exact and that's what so many
people think so many people think that
is what we're looking for in the
military
unfortunately as represented in the
authoritarian personality they are only
skin deep a brittle crust of defenses
against feelings of weakness and
inadequacy the authoritarian keeps up
his spirits by whistling in the dark he
is frightened he is the frightened child
who wears the armor of a giant
his mind is a closed is a door locked
and bolted against that which he fears
the most himself
i didn't get much out of that but what i
did get a lot out of what i did get a
lot out of is the fact that
when you hear these
personality traits tough-mindedness
obedience to authority it sounds like
that's what you want your people to be
you watch what's what you want your
soldier to be you don't it's not what
you want
it's not what we're looking for
fast forward a little bit
before going on there's one further
point it concerns the distinction that
has been drawn between irrational
authoritarianism as dealt with here and
so-called rational authoritarianism so
this is just a clarification here
by the latter
is meant the readiness to accept and
obey the dictates of a rational
authority cool so p there's there's such
a thing he's basically making a
distinction here
an irrational antipathy toward all
authority is evident in some cases of
student militancy may just be maybe just
as neurotic as non-adaptive as a
predisposition toward irrational
authoritarianism the common denominator
of irrational authoritarianism and blind
anarchy is that both states of mind are
compulsive and derive from an underlying
ego pathology
in fact this distinction between
rational and irrational authoritarianism
has been implied throughout this book
without the exercise this is why i had
to read this part without the exercise
and acceptance of rational authority
without certain minimal levels of
discipline
and even without certain features of
[__]
military organizations would cease to
function this is something i have to
talk about sometime with um
with
clients at epsilon front because
decentralized command we want to have
decentralized command decentralized
command decentralized command we want
subordinates to be able to make choices
and make decisions
and occasionally i'll get him get a
group that's going too wild with that
and all of a sudden where
nothing is centralized anymore and i
have to bring up the fact that hey
guess what kind of uniform
every guy in tasking the bruiser wore a
matching uniform why because we couldn't
have some guy that was wearing a pair of
blue jeans and a sweatshirt out in
ramadi because they would look they
wouldn't look the same and therefore
they get shot what happens if i run out
of bullets guess what i can get bullets
from someone else because we're all
using the same weapon what about my
radio i can use my radio and i can pick
up your radio and use it too why because
we're using the same radio so you have
to have some level of centralization
some level of
authoritarianism that we're all going to
kind of be on the same page
he says then it's necessary to labor
this point because of some of the
semantic confusion regarding the term
authoritarian
throughout this book it refers to
irrational authoritarianism
for the so-called rational
authoritarians and we prefer the praise
autocratic behavior
the terms are not synonymous whereas the
autocrat exercises tight control in the
situation demands that the authoritarian
is himself tightly controlled no matter
what the external situation
a little semantics there
he goes in this next chapter education
of the cult of muscular christianity
okay
this is where he starts talking about
um
you know the british schools how these
kids were raised in sort of like this
musk what he calls muscular christianity
not not kids but some of the kids in
this time frame were raised this way
here's here's some of the things that
are highlighted by the reasons for this
stultifying educational program are no
doubt many and various but to deserve
particular consideration
so this is the education program that
some of these kids were subjected to
the first resides in the belief that
enforced application to unpleasant
boring tasks develops character
and the second that any truly
intellectual exercise by which is meant
the cultivation of independent thinking
as opposed to rote learning
harms that fine sense of loyalty and
obedience which shuts which such schools
strive to inculcate
to think is to question and to question
is to have doubts so he gives some
examples of how these kids were raised
what they did at these schools you know
they were playing sports they were do
hazing rituals and memorizing things and
it was all i mean this is this is true
to this day you know we've got this sort
of school system which is meant to teach
you to be a good worker
that's what it's meant to do meant to
teach you to be a good worker
they don't want that's why they
structure things it's like hey some of
the stuff that you learn in school has
no value whatsoever they're just trying
to get you to follow the rules
do what they say
get on board with the program and fall
in line with the authoritarian rulers
yeah so we got to be careful of that
yeah yeah sometimes you feel like
they whoever they are or doing it on
purpose and sometimes you just feel like
bro i think this is just some curriculum
that like no one had the like
gusto to just be like hey we're doing an
overhaul yeah
i think you're right i think that at
some point like right now let's face it
if you were to go
ground zero and restart your educational
system in america it'd be totally
different than it is right now yeah well
it is slowly changing it is slowly
changing and i'm not even sure that the
way that they're changing is the right
direction i think they're taking
advantage of the fact that it might not
have been the best and they're changing
it to make it worse in some cases
oh yeah yeah and i think in a from a
social standpoint i think they might
have been kind of too hard in a certain
direction kind of crazy sometimes what
kids are learning in school disturbing
in some cases what kids are learning in
school oh yeah
my only point of reference is my element
of the elementary schools that my kids
go to i got the full spectrum from
elementary school through college
do you think um
what was i just thinking about just now
and i'm not really in support of it
yeah oh okay
do you think
i don't know the answer to this but i
just i do kind of consider the other
side of this you know how you just said
um the school kind of is structured to
provide or to develop good workers right
aren't most people workers anyway
not necessarily
no no you want to know something what i
think is messed up now is i think a lot
of times the school right now is to
develop people to go to college and feed
the academic
growth of colleges yeah but even that
hey we're just trying to get you to get
oh you know it'd be good for you to get
a degree in freaking basket weaving or
whatever and no one needs a degree in
that there's a lot of degrees that you
get that you don't need if you want to
learn about that stuff go read about it
don't pay 200 000
and go into debt to learn about
something that has no
it doesn't give you a skill set that
always felt like a social
problem to me yeah it felt like i don't
freaking know when i was a kid
not not not a kid but when i was when i
joined the military i already i used to
use the term i don't know if it's ever
caught on or i don't know if i've ever
heard it but educational inflation
because when i was a kid if you dropped
out of high school you could still get a
job and
have a normal life
then as i got to high school it was hey
listen you gotta finish high school if
you don't finish high school you can't
get a job blah blah blah
then it was that i joined the military
thank god i joined the military but as i
joined the military it was hey you know
you need to really get your whatever
what's a two-year degree your
association your associates you need to
get your associates get some you know
good some and then it became bachelors
and now you've got kids that are going
getting their masters and then their
doctorate right they spend their they
spend they're 33 years old 35 years old
29 years old before they're even getting
a job
and they racked up i mean this is all
now it's all common like everyone's
racking up three four hundred thousand
dollars two hundred thousand three
hundred thousand dollars worth of debt
yeah
and the skill set that they got
in whatever degree they got it gets them
a twenty nine thousand no no probably
not probably a thirty eight thousand
dollar a year job as a whatever you know
whatever
right it's whereas if you would have
gone to if you would have dropped out of
high school
and become an apprentice welder right
now you'd be making 128 grand a year
yeah because you're a hard worker and by
the way if you're smart you start you
know you get you figure out that welding
thing and you buy a a couple welding uh
a couple welding machines and you're
like you know what i can get two guys i
can apprentice them i can teach them
boom you can grow you can make stuff
happen meanwhile the person that has 38
000 a year job they actually have no
skill set yeah
so i think a lot of the educational
system right now
is a feeder program
for the college system which is going to
charge people money and this is sort of
like the housing crash too so the
housing crash came
because the government was loaning money
or backing up loans to people that
aren't going to be able to afford it
that was that was what one of the causes
one of the primary causing of the
housing crash
right now the government backs up these
loans that these people get
and so they're allowed to get loans for
200 300 000
and they don't realize it
they should but they don't realize that
hey you know how long it takes to pay
off a 300 000 loan which is by the way
is the only loan that you can't go
bankrupt from it's gonna and you're
making thirty nine thousand dollars a
year and by the way my my daughter just
graduated college in the spring
and a really good college and
her friends are making 39 000 a year
42 000 a year
like they're not making a lot of money
so i think a lot of the what used to
feed the workers
now feeds into this
into this educational nightmare of
college debt and loans and all that yeah
that's what's kind of nice about what
we're doing at origin because at origin
you don't need a college education you
can go get a job and get a skill yeah
and have a career
right and we've got people that have
careers now that have learned a skill
that's a highly valuable skill
and they don't have any debt
because they didn't go and study basket
weaving for four years at forty two
thousand dollars a year
leaving always gets a bad rap
it almost seems like actually basket
weaving would be a better skill than
some of the degrees that people are
getting right i would basically leaving
would be a skill you could sell baskets
yeah but didn't do right we need to stop
harassing basket weavers
it's almost like but it feels ah i don't
know i'm not an economist or nothing
like this you know that um
it kind of seems like that there's
certain times and then education is kind
of like trying to facilitate those times
right then you have people running the
education um
and then the times change
and then education just follows up with
the with the change but just way way too
late like
might even be 50 to 70 years late oh
yeah and then things so now think about
it consider that so now that now it
changes from like just straight up
factory workers
to
you know a little bit more advanced
workers types right so now it's like
okay really the change that should have
been made long time ago is first for you
to be influenced to go to college get a
higher education
right because you have higher level jobs
generally speaking you know lower level
jobs always going to exist and all this
stuff but just generally speaking it's
just general so
boom now everyone should be going to
college a long time ago they should be
doing that they want to get a degree
that creates way more opportunities back
then there's not all these crazy degrees
like now there's plenty of degrees when
i went to college like they started
doing this program called liberal
freaking studies right which in concept
concept it's it's good
the concept is good but
all you got to do is get your little
degree approved and you can just study
whatever you want essentially and be
like yeah my degree is in this as long
as the title was approved you can get it
it's called liberal studies but it's and
then you have a title for it
again you start doing it just for the
sake of getting a degree but when you
get out of college you know you you
could be jammed up that's what i just
said exactly right but okay and that's
the later part of it but so now you have
when i say it's a social thing or it
feels like a social thing it's kind of
like people are still stuck in that
little zone that's like it is beneficial
to go to college because there was a
point they're stuck in that zone they
think they think that they think that oh
you what are you doing i'm gonna go to
college because that's gonna put me on
the path yeah and they don't realize
that it's not the past that's not the
reality right now so much has changed
and then you have all these people who
um
like back in the day you said people can
drop out of high school and get a job
because yeah you can drop out of high
school because all you have to do is
know how to read and do basic arithmetic
and get a job somewhere like at a
factory or edit you know one of the jobs
that were freaking prevalent in the for
those times as times change you need a
little bit more education now for these
true and untrue well there are always
guess what there's i mean there there is
massive jobs that are you know carpentry
concrete plumber electrician auto
mechanic driver like there's all these
jobs that you definitely do not need a
college education to have yes you do not
need it oh yeah and those are awesome
jobs and they those those people go out
and build america
but to your point are you talking about
right now though i'm talking about right
now those jobs fully exist but here's to
your point
a lot of people would say okay
hey what should i do with my life
and the first nine things that come up
on their list are go to college go to
college go to college go to college
whereas when i was in high school
maybe the first thing would be to go to
college but the second thing was like
become an apprentice electrician
you know like i took electricity in high
school and you're saying that was kind
of the social kind of i think that was
way more normal
there wasn't there wasn't the mandatory
track to college
and i think nowadays almost every kid is
being told go to college go to college
go to college instead of saying hey you
can go and become an apprentice
electrician and that's a freaking great
job and you can have a great life
and you can
contribute to society in a massive way
doing something you enjoy because look
when i was in high school i didn't want
to be looking at books
right i wanted i would much rather be an
electrician
much rather be an electrician
yeah and and yeah i think the zone where
okay
basically break it into these two things
where the social influence like hey you
should go to college or you should
whatever or it's okay not to go to
college you can just get a job here
whatever this that passes and changes
through time
the social to me the social part is
lagging like way behind the reality yes
that's what i'm saying yes so there was
a little zone where it was the best to
go to college if you had that
opportunity that was the zone
right here and right now socially the
influence is still in that zone they're
still saying it's starting to change
though you you start to hear people
being like hey that's awesome
people saying that stuff yes but it's i
think it's still there the reality on
the streets is bro college is
for a handful of people and that's it
yeah i want to say yeah there's people
out there that are actually hiring
they're not looking for college degrees
and i'm talking sir like i think peter
thiel is one of them
and he's out there saying
we'll test i don't know if they got a
testing program but they're saying we
just want smart people it doesn't matter
whether you went to college or not yeah
that's freaking legit and here's how you
know here's how you can kind of
it's kind of like a finger on the ball
like this how you can kind of tell that
people are still in the zone of like
college is a good thing you can be like
oh yeah that guy has a degree from from
harvard
it's like a total appeal appeal to
authority the college being the
authority by the way you don't even have
to say what he has a degree from yeah
you can say he has a degree from harvard
and that automatically i'm not saying
that's it but i'm just saying that in
and of itself is a point yeah like a
positive thing yeah i'm saying that yeah
are you ready if we get past this zone
they'll be like so what's it in what's
he doing you know what's funny is i
actually hear that right now i'm
starting to
i and people that i know for sure are
starting to hear like oh oh that person
has their mba or whatever yeah whatever
yeah yeah so we're already getting there
it's
we're not getting there but we're moving
in that direction i hear those comments
check uh back to education here
finally and perhaps the most fatal of
all the private schools ethic of honor
and fair play so admirable in itself
leads to disastrous results when
mistakenly imputed to those like hitler
who played the game by different center
rules so these kids were told hey you
gotta follow the rules and this we play
with honor and then hitler's like oh
really watch this
this particular weakness of military
endeavor continued to feature in many
subsequent campaigns indeed is no
exaggeration to say that an absence of
adequate
uh reconnaissance the refusal to believe
intelligence reports and a general
horror of spying
have tended to keep our armies wrapped
in cocoons of catastrophic ignorance
this fatal preference for honorable
ignorance rather than useful knowledge
gleaned by devious means was not
confined to soldiers in the field but
as an attitude of mind permeated the
highest levels of all military
intelligence so another thing these this
is what these kids got educated to do
they got educated to
live with honor that means we're not
going to sneak around we're not going to
cheat you know i had to watch out for
that you know sometimes you get to like
well ieds for cowards like okay we get
it that's for cowards but guess what's
for cowards ieds roadside right
yo that that's a coward yeah yeah sure
it is guess what we have to contend with
it
just because it's cowardly doesn't mean
it's going to go in it doesn't mean it
doesn't produce dead bodies and main
bodies
is it cowardly yes it is how do we
counter it
until you put some sniper over watches
on some roads and swag some people
that's how you counter it
like a reformed
because enormously successful burglar
who self-righteously puts down his jimmy
to take up proselytizing on the evils of
crime we took to repudiating these very
traits push cleverness ruthlessness and
cheer naked aggression
that had put us where where we are the
reason so what he's saying is
you like a criminal
that sort of makes it and like all of a
sudden puts down his thieving tools and
starts saying you know thieving is bad
and you should live a righteous way yeah
but he's forgetting about how he got
there
and what he's what the point he's making
here is we can have a tendency to do
that like hey
in war if you got to be brutal we're
we're on top because we were brutal yeah
we're on top because we spied and you
know broke [__] and killed people that's
what got us here
and we can't now sit up here well that's
all wrong
you've got to be careful about that
now we get to part three of this book
well interestingly enough you want to
hear what quote it starts off there's no
bad regiments only bad officers ah we've
heard napoleon say it we've heard
hackworth say it yes sir we've heard
echelon front say we we we know that
quote
is an extreme ownership well it's we use
a different quote no bad teams only bad
leaders is what we said
did we steal it um yes we stole it from
hackworth
who'd hackworth steal it from
field marshal lord slim who is in world
war one world war ii
uh wounded three times
and guess what he stole it from napoleon
so we're stealing it we're using it
can't steal what's free okay
we're attributing
also too much of history is written as
though men had no feelings no childhood
no bodily senses
which is
which is something that i have
tried with all my might
with this podcast to make sure that
history is written
and it's clear that these men had
feelings
had bodily senses had childhoods and
beyond that had hopes and dreams for the
future a lot of history's not written
like that
section here called the worst and the
best so now what he does is
he starts
pointing out some and this is why i can
start moving a little bit faster i told
you before we even started recording
like hey there's a big chunk of the book
we're going to cover we're going to
cover in one podcast because
he starts going into a lot of details
and it's worth reading you have to get
the book if you want to read all these
things but he starts pointing out the
worst and the best
of some of these military leaders
he said this about hitler or does john
strassen said this about hitler in a war
from which so much human error had been
eliminated by technological advances
alone human error was still the
principal factor in determining war's
outcome
hitler slipknot
a little bit about hitler hitler's
particular brand of military
incompetence is precisely what one would
expect he showed a total unconcern for
the physical and psychological welfare
of his men in his armies and we man when
we covered stalingrad remember we
covered stalingrad on this podcast
actually a book called stalingrad was
written by a nazi soldier and they were
they were listening on the radio
as they were surrounded
and they were listening to hitler talk
about
praising their
dying to the last man
that's like insane
uh number two his this imperviousness to
human suffering which resulted in such
enormous wastage of his own forces was a
contributory factor in his stubborn
refusal to ever relinquish gained ground
three from
his extreme ethnocentrism came another
well-known form of military incompetence
that which results from a gross
underestimation of the enemy and in
particular of the ability of civilian
populations to withstand the effect of
war yep
thinking that your uh you know nazi
soldiers are just superior and then you
come up against the russian civilians
and they're like what
won't play
and and thinking that they're just going
to fold
thinking that the russians are just the
russian civilian populace and and even
their red army which is you know made up
of you know peasant soldiers
they're going to fold under the might of
the of the nazis
you might want to check yourself homie
while many of foreign while many of
hitler's decisions were military
disastrous his underlying ego weakness
and fear of criticism eventually in
several other traits which are
undesirable
to say the least in a military senior
commander he promoted his aides and
advisors for their sick efficiency
rather than their ability
just promoting people because they
sucked up to him he refused to accept
believe or even listen to unpalatable
intelligence and when things got went
really wrong he was the first to find
scapegoats the opposite of extreme
ownership
promoting people because they kissed
your ass
not listening to
intel that's coming in this is having a
closed mind
being an idiot
like his henchman himmler even hitler
could on occasion show that over control
of aggression that procrastination which
has enca incapacitated some other
authoritarian military commanders
perhaps his most disastrous decision of
the war was when he halted the german
advance before dunkirk thus allowing the
british to escape
finally on on april 22 1945 hitler
failed as a military commander in a way
that he had never failed before in
abdicating the responsibility he
betrayed his command and if you're
abandoned leadership and duty-like so
yeah he quit
he he's the ultimate quitter dord
diord drop-on request on april 22 1945
and then a few days later on april 30th
killed himself
he could also commit
enormous blunders and these when they
occurred seem less a product of
stupidity than of his total sustained
all-pervasive authoritarian so that's an
important point hitler made all these
mistakes and did all this dumb [__] but
he wasn't dumb
what was driving that
what was driving that his ego yeah his
ego
his his psychopathy his authoritarian
nature all those things not stupid
so you can be really smart and do really
dumb things because you're authoritarian
because your ego is out of control etc
some good examples
um
general sir james wolff
he was bitterly and unfashionably
opposed to what he called the spirit
breaking tactics of horse punishment and
drill
was quite prepared to disobey orders if
these conflicted with what he knew was
right now he's just going through like
these are the opposite of authoritarian
personalities this guy sir james wolf
i'm gonna burn through some of these at
the risk of making himself unpopular he
forced his officers to attend the
attend to the welfare of their men to
visit their living quarters have regard
for their health and generally get to
know them as fellow human beings
wellington
next guy he highlights here wellington
did not evince signs of emotional
restriction did not remain unmoved by
human suffering suffering did not seek
popularity was unimpressed by bull and
did not seek scapegoats for his military
setbacks this is a good leader
he spurned the decorations of authority
large staffs sentries gold braids
so he didn't want to be all dressed up
wellington's self-confidence is also
reflected in his refusal to make
scapegoats of others
thus of the burgos fiasco he said i see
that a disposition already exists to
blame the government for the failure of
the siege of burgos it was entirely my
own act
thankfully he didn't put that into a
book and call it extreme ownership
otherwise i would have been kind of out
of luck
because that's what he did right here's
the bad situation that unfolded during
this siege and he took ownership of it
didn't blame anybody
as usual after a battle his mood was set
by the losses not the glory on the
morning after the siege
another wellington showed himself to his
deeply astonished staff he visited the
dead
and on seeing so many of his finest men
destroyed he broke down and wept
that's not authoritarian
finally he displayed an open
an open mind to new ideas quick to
innovate and see advantages in the
progress of technology he was remarkably
laissez-faire regarding the dress of his
soldiers
thirdly he did not commit that cardinal
error of so many military incompetence
underestimation of the enemy
he took infinite plans pains in military
planning left nothing to chance selected
officers for their efficiency
always did recon so you can see what
he's getting at here shaka
the zulu king
of his general ship it has been written
shaka's particular
genius laying his meticulous personal
attention to detail and sheer hard work
if at all possible he always insisted on
inspecting everything himself in every
one of his critical battles he insisted
on personal
rick and ordering the ground and the
disposition of enemy forces he
invariably checked all reports by
procuring collateral evidence
shaka could also be humane he talks
about shaka actually
um
being pretty brutal to his men which i
don't
i was a little bit thinking well why are
you trying to give this guy as this
great example
um those who hesitated to follow his
example and painful initiation were
instantly clubbed to death
seems a little authoritarian to me bro
dixon where you at i mean we're cutting
some slack here so here's the deal uh
another example of his flexibility and
refusable to dominate by tradition was
shaka's banning of sandals for his
fighting men by making them run barefoot
a considerable and by no means popular
break with tradition he invested his
army the speed of movement far in excess
of that achieved by his enemies the
displeasure
he incurred through this innovation was
hardly reduced by an order
to his warriors that they should harden
their feet on the parade ground strewn
with thorns
those who hesitated to follow in his
example in this painful tradition were
instantly clubbed to death
seems worth being a little authoritarian
there bro
button then it says this shaka could
also be humane as well as
[Music]
punitive
in caring for his army to ensure that
his fighting men were kept warm well
rested and well fed and orderly was
provided for every three soldiers under
his command no battle was fought without
adequate supplies of food water and bark
dressings being assembled at strategic
points beforehand it can be summed up as
autocratic totally non-authoritarian
high in achievement motivation and yet
capable of great warmth and sympathy
according to ritter this guy wrote about
him he was highly emotional and
sentimental behind a facade of iron iron
self-discipline the fact that he was the
finest composer of songs
the leading dancer and wittiest punster
suggests an artist who would naturally
have a highly strong nature and more
sensitive than the calmer common run of
the nyangi race
so there's shakka
napoleon
the evidence suggests that though he was
ambitious ruthless devious unscrupulous
grandiose
despotic
machiavellian dictatorial and autocratic
he was not authoritarian again this is
where he's getting some semantics here
that's kind of like
napoleon could be the reverse of extra
punitive the fault he argued lay not so
much with the men as with himself
so he he when things were didn't go the
way he wanted he often said it was his
fault cool
i think he's stretching man on napoleon
a little bit
i i because i think it's it's a scale
right and and napoleon i think had an
open mind when it came to combat you
know but i think he was an egomaniac i
mean we have a free what's that a
napoleon complex right like you're all
little and you are trying to be big
stern and imperius two in his business
hours napoleon was all ease and sunshine
to his intimates they admired his
pleasant wit
his unaffected gay to his rich and
brilliant handing of moral and political
themes so he's trying to make him out to
be a little less authoritarian than he
was in my opinion
but some of these guys even the guys
chaka zulu he was
maybe he was authoritarian
in certain ways that's why that's what i
just said it's a scale right or whatever
in other ways and it kind of found
struck a balance yeah so like
back to um shaka he he would
be not what is the one what's the
opposite authoritarian
authoritarian liberal whatever
yeah
he was anti
except when it came to those feet man
those feet got you know like you gotta
like how you guys say you gotta hold the
line on some stuff yeah you know those
radios you got to know how to program
your radios sure but the patches yeah
that's sliders
so shaco was like that with a lot of
stuff so
kind of keeping it real kind of kind of
keeping it real kind of keeping it real
you know but that's how right that's the
dichotomy yeah right that's the
dichotomy and i think that's he's trying
to point out some of that dichotomy i
think he's leaning to try and show these
good leaders as being less authoritarian
yeah um because napoleon i mean sure you
know
hitler napoleon these guys like yeah
they lost and they lost huge and they're
bad
but they did some effective stuff oh
yeah well napoleon's i mean napoleon won
a lot
and hitler won a lot too man that's what
i'm saying blitzcraig kicking it off
took over
giant
swaths of europe napoleon did the same
thing
so there was definitely some
they did some [__] that was that they
won it was effective yeah yeah and by
the way there's other people that were
totally authoritarian that did
authoritarian [__] and law and and also
won yeah the crimean war
right with the brits the brits were
doing the dumbest
most horrible authoritarian ego driven
moves and
getting guys killed by the bushel
and yet they still were able to win
um
this is a little bit more about napoleon
finally like many of the other
commanders on our list napoleon was
without that vanity this like struck me
bro without that vanity which betoken's
a weak ego was notoriously careless
about his dress had a wide range of
intellectual interests and promoted his
subordinates on the basis of their
efficiency okay so that's cool makes
sense
nor did he display the debilitating over
control of aggression which is on
occasions paralyzed warlike behavior
of less successful commanders
nelson
nelson did not display a compulsive
concern with ordinance of his dress was
anxious to give pleasure to everyone
about him distinguishing each turn by
some act of kindness and chiefly those
who seem to require it the most so
nelson seems like he's just a really
good guy any residual doubts one might
have regarding nelson's freedom from the
crippling effects of weak ego should be
resolved by considering his most famous
characteristic disobedience
possessing boundless moral courage he
was himself prepared to disobey if he
thought it to the advantage of his
country
and often he was right nelson was in
fact always urging others even allies
superiors and officials of the army to
disregard their orders if necessary
in what he thought was to be the general
interest of the cause
this is one of the best
quotes on decentralized command
i have ever heard in my life
so this is
nelson
nelson's own view of this matter was
uncomplicated
as he said to the duke of clarence
to serve my king
and to destroy the french i consider as
the great order of all from which little
ones spring
and if one of these little ones militate
against it
for who can exactly tell at a distance i
go back and obey the great order and
object end quote
that's a beautiful understanding of
decentralized command here's what we're
trying to get done and there's a bunch
of different ways you can get it done if
i'm telling you to do something but it
doesn't quite make sense in supporting
the strategic goal don't do it do
something else
so that's a
non-authoritarian
mindset
which is good to go t lawrence lawrence
of arabia
of his general ship liddell heart wrote
lawrence can bear comparison
with marlboro or napoleon in that vital
faculty of generalship the power of
grasping instantly the picture of the
ground and situation of relating the one
to the other and the local to the
general oh he was able to see what was
happening not just what's happening
right there but see it in the big
picture he's able to detach take a step
back look around
i think strategic liddell heart
considered that lawrence also showed the
same profound quote profound
understanding of human nature
the same power of commanding affection
while commanding energy
and the same consummate blend of
diplomacy with strategy
had a cool head
lodell heart also considered that
lawrence the most widely read of
generals was morris was more steeped in
knowledge of war than any other generals
of the last war
in personality this one read a little
bit more because
well because of this in personality
lawrence is probably the least
authoritarian senior commander of the
world has ever known
he was totally without personal ambition
refused promotion honors and awards for
himself and deplored the pomp vanities
and ritualized bowing and scraping which
one associates with the power structure
of the hierarchical command systems
we like this guy right out of the gate
you're like yeah we're down with this
guy
the fact that he could renounce his name
for that of ross and later shaw and
happily resume his role of a lowly
ranker after achieving worldwide fame
indicates a degree of self-effacement
quite unique amongst military men
contrary to a characteristic
predisposition of authoritarian
individuals
lawrence disliked interfering with other
men's freedom
god
you can't impose on other people you
shouldn't impose on other people you
shouldn't mess with their freedom
he disliked giving orders
and in fact exercised effective command
largely through the tendering of advice
have you ever have you ever heard leif
babin explain how many times i gave him
a direct order
well yes i have i have heard him explain
sometimes zero zero times
that this advice was acted upon suggests
that by his personality he achieved a
level of leadership rarely attained by
military commanders
he himself was prepared to obey foolish
orders but disliked passing these on to
others as liddell hart remarks in war
such orders are often the result useless
sacrifice of men's lives in peace they
often contribute to the sterilization of
men's reason oh that's a good one
you bark orders you make people do what
you want what you want them to do you're
gonna sterilize their brain
lawrence was a great respecter of reason
and considered that the possession of
knowledge was of primary importance for
a military leader in his opinion quote
the perfect general would know
everything in heaven and earth and quote
by the same token this most open-minded
of men
deplored the closed and vacus minds of
his military compatriots a men who
displayed a quote fundamental
crippling
incuriousness so there you go
t e lawrence
we got slim who this thing kicked off
with general slim like so many generals
when plans have gone wrong oh we take a
little bit of ownership here
like so many generals there's a quote
when so many generals like so many
generals when plans have gone wrong i
could find plenty of excuses
but only one reason myself
when two courses of action were open to
me
i had not chosen as a good commander
should the boulder i had taken counsel
of my fears patent reference
there is no evidence here
of that telltale defense projection and
even though he had ample opportunity for
making scapegoats of those subordinates
who had given giving the advice which
ended failure so you got another guy
slim had he written a book
and taken you know giving it a cool
title like extreme ownership
we'd be in a different spot right now
taken into account with other traits his
warmth towards his family his absence of
rigidity is parsimony with the lives of
his men his ability to improvise his
popularity with the troops and relative
lack of concern regarding his popularity
with his equals it should come as no
surprise to learn that the chivalrous
autocratic and most efficient of
generals enjoyed a happy childhood
apparently unmarred by those stresses
and strange which may weaken the ego and
stunt the personality
he kind and i've been skipping these
parts a little bit i guess i'm being a
little bit biased but i'm skipping a lot
like psycho analysis
because you know that and i'm just
giving you that little taste of them you
want to get some of that you got to kind
of get into it here a little bit
and this next section is
exceptions to the rule
got a little quote here from rommel
one must not judge everyone in the world
by his qualities as a soldier otherwise
we should have no civilization that's
rommel to his son interesting
incompetence is not confined to those
who were extreme in their ineptitude but
may operate along a line of a continuum
of military excellence from worst to the
best senior commanders
and military shortcomings of montgomery
kitchener and hague and their positions
along a dimension of authoritarian
authoritarianism are perfectly
correlated so this is what you were
saying earlier
it's not like oh
this is uh that you're either
authoritarian or you're not
you could be anywhere on this spectrum
and as we have been discussing
you want to have some level of
authoritarianism you just don't want too
much it's got to be a balance but some
people can be oh they're a little bit in
the red
right some people full green maybe some
some people too much green they don't
even make it but i think in the military
people that are far green don't even
join the military yeah right we got to
remember that people not even in there
yeah so you already have a composite of
people that are a little bit
at least in the middle maybe a little
bit orange some people leaning in the
red
but it's a it's a continuum
um talking about montgomery and again
you got to get if you want the details
of this read get the book it's not my
purpose to debate montgomery's greatness
suffice it to say that while
not without blemishes he was in the main
a highly competent commander and as such
needs to be considered in present
context does he or does he not support
the hypothesis that competence depends
upon an absence of authoritarianism and
its associated traits so so that's what
we're really hearing there is that the
more authoritarian you are the worse
you're going to be
unless you have zero authoritarianism
and he points out some things that makes
him not authoritarian is
authoritarianistic here's montgomery
lack those obsessive traits which tend
to accompany authoritarianism he's not
particularly mean or particularly
obstinate and judging from his own dress
and lenient attitude towards that of his
troops he did not harbor any compulsive
urge for a bull
in this as in other matters his approach
was essentially realistic
seems that whatever else he may be
montgomery does not evince a
well-documented signs of
authoritarianism and yet even in this
case there remains the undisputable fact
that for all his greatness as a military
commander montgomery did have serious
shortcomings which could not be
attributed to a lack of professional
ability so montgomery did some jacked up
things and we covered in one of the
earlier podcasts we also covered it on a
podcast not about this book
these lapses were
an inability to get along with many of
his military colleagues like kitchener
he had a knack of making himself
enormously unpopular with his
contemporaries and preferred the company
of younger and more junior officers it
was a bad sign i was talking about this
on the academy the other day extreme
ownership.com
somebody's talking about they can't get
along
if you're not getting along with people
you're doing a bad job
what's wrong with you why aren't you
getting along with people
you should be getting along with people
it's part of your job build
relationships what's happening with you
montgomery's second shortcoming was that
he sometimes allowed his own desire for
personal glory to influence planning a
military plan tainted by an attempt to
satisfy the commander's ego is unlikely
to be the best plan an irrelevant factor
has been introduced into the calculation
clearly that's jacked up montgomery's
next shortcoming presents something of a
paradox it concerns a matter of
communication for a man who is adept at
simplifying the apparently complex whose
ability to extract the
essentials from a host of irrelevant
factors was second to none who could
communicate his intentions and issue
orders to his subordinates with a
lucidity that left no room for
misinterpretation and who could write
his memoirs with such a style that puts
most generals to shame it is
extraordinary that he should have been
almost incapable of explaining himself
to those above him in the chain of
command
kind of crazy
got a whole big explanation on on
montgomery and where some of that stuff
came from fast forward a little bit to
kitchener kitchener who became secretary
of state in the first world war had
according to philip magnus two basic
attributes an unparalleled thoroughness
and an unparalleled drive he was an
individual individualist of great
conceptions whose hard and selfless
nature was capable at times of kindness
sympathy and even affection these traits
his excessive drive
lord corzone once described kitchener as
this molten mass of devouring energy his
individualism and his refusal to conform
the originality of his thinking and the
occasional flashes of underlying warmth
and generosity are hard to reconcile
with the notion of authoritarianism so
he's got montgomery who has some
authoritarianism
kishner's a little bit more
and as we as we push through his
authoritarianism
from kitchener for all his greatness
kitchener seems to have been a victim of
the repressive forces and planted him as
a child
presumably is a marionette of his father
and then
psychoanalytics going on
but what were those traits regardless of
where they came from his aloofness his
unpopularity with many of his fellow
officers his failure to work as part of
a team and most damaging of all his
latter day indecisiveness and hesitancy
in directing gallipoli campaign must be
ascribed to defects of the personality
rather than intellect and again it's
just interesting to point out that
authoritarianism you'd think that makes
people make calls
but it actually freaks them out in these
pressure situations because they don't
want to get they don't they don't they
don't handle failure they don't know
what to do and they just they don't want
to do anything back off
whereas somebody that's a little less
authoritarian's like okay you know what
we've got to make a call here that's
what we're doing
now we get to hague
and trying to answer the question
whether the recurring features of
military incompetence derive from
aspects of the authoritarian personality
even in a commander who ultimately
emerged victorious one could not do
better than consider the case of douglas
hague commander-in-chief of the british
armies on the western front between 1915
and 1918.
judging from the war of wars which has
raged between his detractors and
devotees there was never a more
controversial military commander here's
some quotes hague britain's number one
war criminal
expected germans to advance in this
attack and at the same time slow at the
same slow pace of his own clumsily
planned results another quote he seemed
to be most highly equipped thinker in
the british army that's totally
different quote
another quote hague perhaps failed to
see that a dead man cannot advance and
that to replace him is only to provide
another corpse here's another quote it
is indeed strange that the man whose
stubbornness in the offensive had all
but ruined us on the psalm should from
august 1918 onwards have been become the
driving force of the allied armies that
is crazy you freaking conduct this
horrible operation so many people die
and you just continue being in charge
and directing operations
hague was unimaginative
maybe he was competent according to his
lights but these were dim
confidence of divine approval appeared
to satisfy him nothing can excuse the
casualties of the psalm and
passchendaele
world war one freaking nightmare
so what's up with his personality did
hague evince those character traits that
are associated with authoritarianism he
certainly had most of them first he was
conservative conventional and in his
attitude toward the french ethnocentric
his diary and dispatches suggest he was
unemotional and totally
anti-interceptive i.e not able not one
to reflect upon his own motives
he was manifestly lacking in compassion
towards his fellow men it's just so
important as you hear these things just
to think
what do you think a military commander
should be like and what should a
military commander actually be like
he was a confirmed believer in the
direction of events by supernatural
powers and reserved to the point of
being verbally almost inarticulate hague
also betrayed that triad of traits which
according to contemporary research
defines the obsessive character and
correlated
and is correlated with authoritarianism
he was obstinate orderly and mean
about his obstinacy little further need
to be said from the beginning to the end
his handling of the third eprays be
token an obstinacy of
statuesque proportions this guy would
just stop or never change his mind we're
sticking with the plan
for the second trait in his dress habits
and appearance hague was immaculate
orderly and quite probably the cleanest
man on the western front a contemporary
of of his at clifton remembered him
particularly for his cleanliness a
remarkable attribute to be recalled of a
fellow schoolboy and
for an example of his love of bull
there's this excerpt from a cavalryman
cavalryman's letter quote he had a
personal escort consisting of a full
troop of his own regiment
they were easily the smartest thing in
france not a buckle out of place stripes
of gold for the ncos silver great silver
skull and crossbones end quote other
writers have commented on his meticulous
attention to minute detail and his habit
of planning each day according to a set
pattern
[Applause]
so there you go
and he breaks out basically saying
montgomery
out of those three was the best and had
the least authoritarian nature
little bit more authoritarian a little
bit worse performance and then finally
you get to hague total authoritarian
attitude
and
well the worst
example and the worst leader
and now we're getting to the uh the
final chapter
of this book
six podcast deeps by the way
yes i went hard in the paint
retreat this one's called
hail
ye
indomitable heroes hail despite all of
your generals ye prevail that's from a
landor who wrote a poem about the
crimean heroes and i i just was talking
about this right
the brits won the brits and their allies
beat the russian despite their shitty
leadership
uh klaus switz this difficulty in seeing
things correctly which is one of the
greatest sources of friction and war
makes things appear quite different from
what was expected
good job klaus switz you know what you
better learn how to do if you want to
see things correctly you better learn to
detach you better learn to take a step
back you better learn to put your ego in
check you better learn to get control
over your emotions so you're not seeing
through an egotistical or emotional lens
it is not the intention to leave a
comparable impression of generalship
but rather to show that
the nature of inter-species in the that
the nature of inter-species aggression
predisposes the leaders of armies and
navies to certain sorts of error
so he's saying look when you start
fighting and killing each other it leads
to certain types of error just in its
own right
then he says from dem far from
diminishing the stature of senior
military commanders the existence of
this predisposition makes the
performance of the majority of soldiers
and sailors
doubly credible
so it's so fr there's so much natural
disaster about to happen that when
someone does a good job it's you should
get double credit two gold stars
for being able to pull it off when
there's all this
all this natural gravity towards chaos
mayhem destruction ego
authoritarian personalities like all
that stuff is going on and yet some
people
most
military people from the bottom to the
top do a good job and overcome that
so you should get double the credit
the fear and this is all kind of a
conclusion here the theory advanced in
this book starts from the position that
by its very nature military incompetence
cannot be attributed to the dullness of
intellect we've hammered that point home
there is it seems a reoccurring pattern
to military mishaps which defies any
explanation in terms of the bloody full
theory so these people aren't stupid
it is instead is tentatively suggested
that the syndrome occurs through the
enormous difficulties of
professionalizing the instinctual
activity of intra-species aggression
this professionalism entails the growth
of military militarism that collection
of rules and conventions whereby
hostility is controlled and anxiety
reduced so you've got this system set up
to put command in place to reduce
anxiety to overcome some natural
instincts that's what the military's set
up to do
not surprisingly
a military career attracts a minority of
people with these sort of anxieties
within a military organization their
neurotic needs are gratified they for
their part help to reinforce those very
aspects of militarism which are so
congealed to their requirements in
return as it were for fitting in so well
they may rise to positions of
considerable power once there however
they become incapacitated by the very
characteristics
which hastened their ascent you come in
you're authoritarian you love it you
come in because you're authoritarian and
you want to fit into that then you get
in there and you're gratified because
that and you're advanced because you're
authoritarian
and if you make it all the way up the
chain of command the very authoritarian
traits that you have are actually a
disaster
so this is a horrible thing
and it took me six podcasts to get that
out
so much for a theory based on past
history
has it and he kind of goes like hey look
i've showed you all these examples which
this book 450 pages of this book is
examples and
but he says so much for this theory
based on a past history has it any
relevance for the future since armies
and navies have changed out of all
recognition perhaps the sorts the sorts
of military incompetence described in
these pages are no longer likely to
occur
in fact
the evidence suggests this to be a
forlorn hope so this [__] still happens
some of the same sorts of mistakes occur
now as the as blighted the lives of
soldiers 100 years ago
in vietnam in three weeks in 1968 the
ted offensive alone cost the americans
500 dead in the south vietnamese 165 000
dead with 2 million refugees why did it
happen one reason was the inability to
respond to unexpected military
intelligence
fast forward a little bit any doubts as
to whether the three factors of remote
control he goes into a thing explaining
how
some of the changes that have taken
place one of them is remote control
meaning we now have radios we can
micromanage people out on the
battlefield we make these big swollen
staffs
and and all kinds of weaponry like has
this helped now do we have multiple
people on a staff maybe they can help
sort through some of these people that
are incompetent or we have the power to
like see what's happening on the
battlefield maybe we can make
adjustments through remote control
and we've got all these resources and
weapons maybe that helps so here's what
he said it doesn't help and he says any
doubts to whether these three factors
from remote control swollen staffs and a
wealth of resources make for
incompetence are removed by the
contemplation of vietnam
in this most ill-conceived and horrible
of wars there was the commander-in-chief
lyndon johnson aided by his advisors
dreaming up policies and even selecting
targets at a nice safe distance of 12
000 miles and there was the man on the
spot general westmoreland a by no means
unintelligent military commander but
bemused by the sheer weight of
destructive energy and aggressive
notions supplied by his president
together the machiavellian mind of the
one coupled with the traditional
military mind of the other produced a
pattern of martial lunacy
so abject and appalling that it
eventually did for both of them
like the boo leaders a half century
earlier earlier the versatile general
giap this is the vietnamese north
vietnamese commander and his
commander-in-chief a little old man with
a wispy beard ho chi minh made a huge
professionally trained and over-equipped
army of their enemies look utterly
ridiculous and their leaders helplessly
irate unfettered by traditional
militarism lacking in excessive brute
force and without an obsession with
capturing real estate ho and jiap
relied on poor men's strategy
surprise deception and the ability to
melt away they relied on the fact that
westmoreland would expand expend his
energies swatting wherever they had last
been heard of while they got ready to
sting him somewhere else
yeah and it's it's one of the most
fascinating thing and when we covered um
general mao's like little red book one
thing that's so fascinating about this
is
what the communists do
to win wars is utilize decentralized
command and they do it great and then
for the way they run their government
they decide to make it authoritarian and
centralized which is crazy
which is crazy
and that's exactly what that spells out
right there when we're in battle
decentralized command make things happen
small units out there acting
independently with freedom and then well
for the government guess what we're
gonna lock it all down
you're gonna obey obey obey
this brings up yet another hazard of
modern war government by committee
take the decision to invade cuba with a
group of crew cuban exiles beya pigs in
approving the cia plan kennedy and his
advisors made six assumptions each was
wrong they assumed that no one would
guess the us government was responsible
for the invasion and their contempt for
the cuban air force they assumed it
would be annihilated before the invasion
began they assumed that the small
invasion force led by unpopular
ex-officers from the batista regime
would be more than a match for castro's
weak army of 20 000 well-equipped cuban
troops they assumed that the invasion
would touch off a general revolt behind
castro's line they assumed that even if
unsuccessful in their primary objective
the exile forces the exile force could
hole up in cuba and reinforce
anti-castro gorillas
that's their plan do assumption
assumption assumption assumption in the
event that each assumption proved a
gross mic in the event each assumption
proved a gross miscalculation nothing
went as planned nobody believed the cia
cover story the ships carrying reserve
on ammunition for the invasion force
failed to arrive two were sunk and two
fled by the second day and the the
invaders were surrounded by castro's
army and by the third day they were
either dead or behind bars seven months
later the united states recovered what
was left of their invasion force for a
ransom price to castro 53 million
dollars kennedy was stricken
how could i have been so stupid as to
let them go ahead he asked
as sorenson wrote his anguish was doubly
deepened by the knowledge that the rest
of the world was asking the same
question arthur schlesinger jr noted
that kennedy would sometimes refer
incredulously to the bay of pigs
wondering how a rational and responsible
government could have become involved
and so an ill start adventure
sunday december 7th 1941 had been set
aside by admiral kimmel
commander-in-chief of the pacific fleet
for a friendly game of golf
with his colleague general short
96 of his ships the american fleet slept
at anchor in the harbor american plane
stood wing tip to wingtip on the tarmac
american servicemen were off duty
enjoying weekend leave by the end of the
day pearl harbor with its ships planes
and military installations had been
reduced to smoking ruins 2 000 service
men have been killed and many more
wounded or missing
by the end of the day kimmel was
offering to resign later he was
court-martialed reprimanded and demoted
to a position where he's never again
required to make decisions of any
consequence pearl harbor like the bay of
pigs confirmed once again that military
incompetence is more often a product of
personality characteristics than of
intellectual shortcomings
for these american disasters show very
clearly
that even combined intellects
and specialized knowledge of highly
intelligent and dedicated men are no
proof against decisions so totally
unrealistic and subsequently to tax the
credule
of even those who had made them
far from diminishing the chances of
ineptitude the group actually
accentuates the effects of those very
traits which may lead to incompetence in
individual commanders
so you get go you get a group together
and you'd think that this would kind of
cancel out and i'd say hey echo i don't
that's a good idea no it actually gets
worse it turns into groupthink the
symptoms of this process
which janus terms groupthink include
one an illusion of invulnerability that
becomes shared by most members of the
group
two collective attempts to ignore or
rationalize away items of information
which might otherwise lead the group to
reconsider shaky but cherished
assumptions
three an unquestioned belief in the
group's inherent morality thus enabling
members to overlook ethical consequences
of their decision
four stereotyping the enemy as either
too evil from negotiation or too stupid
and feeble to be a threat
you can see you like hear this this
happening in the room right you can hear
the discussions happening
a shared illusion of unanimity
in a majority viewpoint augmented by the
false assumption that silence means
consent
and six self-appointed
mind guards to protect the group from
adverse information that might shatter
complacency about the effectiveness and
morality of their decisions
so that's what happens when you put a
bunch of people
that have these tendencies into a group
together it gets worse
this is the last thing i'm going to read
from the book here
finally
it is worth noting
that the personality determined malaise
of groupthink produces once again those
four most frequently occurring symptoms
of past military incompetence
wastage of manpower
overconfidence
underestimation of the enemy and
ignoring of intelligence reports
these
it seems
are the enduring hazards
of professionalizing violence
and i can tell you these are not only
the hazards of professionalizing
violence and these are the enduring
hazards
for us as human beings as leaders
that we can all fall into
and as you pointed out this book is a
is a big warning of what not to do
i i gotta i said it was the last thing
i'm going to read but there's a l this
guy's funny and i did a bad job of
relaying some of his humor here's the
afterward
of this book and this is the last thing
i'm going to read from this book after
six podcasts
sure he says
this is so british
he says lest the reader should have
doubted my qualifications to write this
book let me assure him that i have
marked authoritarian traits
a weak ego
fear of failure motivation and no
illusions about the fact that i would
have made a grossly incompetent general
it takes one to no one
that was from the author in 1975. it's a
little bit of humor and you know he says
it takes one to no one
but that's unfortunately not true
it's unfortunately not true
if you think you're incompetent
there's a better chance that you're not
incompetent
you can see where i'm going this if you
think you're incompetent there's a
there's a better chance that you're not
incompetent because if you think you're
incompetent you're you're actually
humble and you're thinking oh you know i
don't
man i need to listen to what other
people have to say
i need to check myself i need to learn i
need to open my mind and see what other
information i can grab because i gather
because i feel like i might be
incompetent
so if you feel it's kind of when people
ask me about the imposter syndrome yeah
what about imposters good
that means you're actually thinking man
do i need to be i always had that i
always felt like oh man if i'm gonna
need to be making decisions i better do
my homework
i better think this through i better pay
attention
so if you think you're incompetent you
probably aren't
but if you've been listening to these
six straight podcasts and you've been
thinking that this book is about all the
uncompetent leaders around you that's a
little warning sign
be careful because if you are in that
mindset where you think oh man i can't
believe how jacked up all these other
leaders are well not you
red flag
because chances are
this is about you
look here's the other red flag it's a
scale right you brought that up it's
it's a it's a continuum yeah
and so we all of us
even if you feel like you're pretty
competent you are
under threat of being dragged to
incompetency so all these little this
book is just a warning sign after
warning sign after warning sign and by
the way there's nothing new
there's almost nothing new there's one
thing that i said that's a new thought
to me i forget what it was
but in these 400 pages and whatever we
just did 12 15 hours worth of podcasts
it's all a it's a rehash it's a
reinforcement of information that i
already knew that we already knew that
we talk about all the time that we've
seen in a bunch of other situations
it's a rehash
but
we're all
getting
you can we can all get pulled
over there we can get pulled towards
that authoritarian mindset because you
know why we get pulled towards the
authoritarian mindset we get pulled
towards that authority mindset because
it seems easier
it seems easier to say shut up and do
what i told you to do it seems easier to
say you know what i'm not going to
listen to that piece of information
it seems easier to do that it seems like
the right move
it seems easier to say you know what the
competitor's never going to be able to
do what we're doing
it seems easier and it's not
so you got to get watched you got to
watch out you got to pay attention
you're going to be careful we all have
to be on guard incompetence incompetence
is out there sort of ready to attack
it's ready to attack yes sir and if
you're not on guard it'll grab you it'll
pull you down and you'll be making bad
decisions and getting people killed or
ruining your business or ruining your
marriage or ruining your life
through incompetence so
we have to pay attention
you got to be careful
uh we got to stay on the path yes sir
the path
speaking of which you know
what do you have for us how do you
advise we we we avoid incompetence
mental incompetence leadership
incompetence physical incompetence
we don't want to have that what do you
got for us echo that was the uh what do
you call the dunning krueger effect
right that you kind of referred to where
the the it takes one to know and that's
not necessarily true
yeah that it
feels like when you
you think you know everything it's like
it's easy to know everything when you
think there's only like three or four
things to know
but then
when you start jiu-jitsu and you're like
man once i know how to stop that arm
lock i'll be good kind of be it yeah
because you got unlocked three times
yeah buy some random you know blue belt
and you're like oh dude i'm gonna stop
that and then you get choked figured it
out didn't you learn how to stop the
joke then you get the heel hooked yeah
it did not stop that heel hook yeah it
just goes on yeah
yeah so the guy well actually it does
stop after like you get heel hooked arm
locked ezekiel choked freaking then you
go oh there's a lot more i don't know
what i'm doing yes so it takes a minute
to convince you of that yeah so that's
when you kind of when the it's all the
dunning-kruger effect it's it's
essentially like yeah when you think you
people who are like so confident they're
the ones that know less than the people
who are like not confident at all
because they know how much there is not
to know almost you know they have a
grasp on it or whatever yeah dave good
deal dave said something i forget his
exact words but i wish i remembered it
was something like oh yeah there when
he's talking about jiu-jitsu he was like
um
yeah it's it's almost like you get what
you you learn what do you say it's
almost like you get worse over time
because yesterday there was only three
things i didn't know like now there's
like 40 things that i don't know kind of
tomorrow there's a thousand years yeah
yeah the day that you
start to look start to feel okay is when
you go oh there's an infinite
i just don't know anything yeah i think
exactly right
well so we want to know stuff hey
complacency right complacency that's one
of the deals it's like your whole brain
and body but brain trying to
trying to like be
lazy
for lack of a better term like i said
before trying to save energy trying to
save work like when you do more work or
less work
yep
see i'm saying it's like a rubik's cube
you're are you good at rubik's cube yeah
you are yeah uh you know the formula yep
i know i know all the algorithms to get
the sides turned up right that's good
well let's say you didn't well actually
not just kidding not new rooms
that kind of surprised me when i was
like damn yeah all right that's like if
you said you knew how to play the piano
but it is an algorithm that you learn
how to do stuff like a little language
for sure little um
steps yes yes exactly right like yeah
it's a little formula for sure um but
whether you know the formula or not i
would imagine that let's say you got
that thing figured out right but then on
one side you got that one freaking
different color
on the side just the one
you know that's not just one move that's
like
you know eighteen hundred moves you
gotta do no not there's like oh you know
the four million it was like 13 moves
left left up two two five i would
imagine it'd be like multiples of four
for some reason i don't know why i think
that but could be right could be wrong
here's the deal let me ask you this what
you know i was the kid and
when rubix creeps came out it took me
like no less than you know 15 minutes to
figure out how to break that thing apart
and reassemble it in the correct order
yeah and and then actually that's smart
to do in a couple
yeah it's creative put it this way yeah
that's the thing well your yours might
i'm not saying you were creative because
i don't know but you seem like the type
you didn't do it out of creativity you
did it just out of like brute [__]
jocko yes
but when you break it not denied
chocolate
just like hey i'm going to solve this
problem the most direct way i can but if
you look at those rubik's cube you take
it all apart
it the last pieces those center pieces
kind of tell a little bit of a story
yeah
they're stuck there well no i think you
can take them out you could pop them off
this
yeah yeah it would make less sense
exactly right that's what i'm saying it
take it tells a little story there so
you're like oh i see you know then maybe
i don't know i don't know what you do
today put them put them back together
here's another way to do it
all the colors are little stickers
oh god yeah
less brute way of doing it a little bit
more sophisticated is what i'm saying i
don't know until you got like glue all
over your freaking hands
i didn't say it was perfect too i didn't
say it was perfect
either way that's the frustration you
got it all figured out
in seconds by the way oh yeah bro
so ruby's cube is what it's nine on each
side right right you've ever seen those
ones with like
freaking like 64 squares on each side or
whatever i have not seen they're they're
nuts and guys will do them too in like a
time lapse or whatever nonetheless
you see my point no i have no idea where
where you think you've got you think you
got things figured out in life right
then you get this this one lone idea
that kind of jams up your whole way of
thinking just that one
it's way easier to take off that sticker
or maybe just turn it to the side where
you can't see that thing it's insane
it's way easier okay save way way more
energy
but the reality is the correct thing to
do is probably you got to know that
algorithm the formula it's going to take
some steps and take some more work but
at the end of the day you're going to
have it correct that's what i think okay
so i'm saying yes
percent bro and that's the way you got
to think in a way so amazing like you
see even even your attitude right now is
telling me that you're you might be
feeling the effects of the the what do
you call it well how'd you put it like
slipping off the slipping
my mind is so close to your freaking
metaphors right now it's ridiculous
anyway we're working out it's squat
season by the way i heard right
apparently it's squat season
so we're so we're on the of staying
there hey look the beginning of squat
season the beginning of any physical
related season
if there's any more than squat season
it's gonna be painful especially in the
beginning
if you go snowboarding
the first day of snowboarding season
that day you're going to have doms you
can be sore so i'm saying anyway
my point is you're going to need some
supplementation here and there you know
no problem we got something for you jaco
has some for you choco fuel that was a
long ramp let's start with the energy
drinks see this is this is this is not
seasonal this is year-round energy drink
which i'm saying but not the tradition
energy drink this is a health healthy
energy drink energy health drink
whatever you want to call it it's all
upside no downside all healthy for you
you'll be healthier after you drink one
or two same same
yep uh by the way there's a new
pre-workout yes sir powder
formula
which
jp danelle did two dry scoops
and then did the chaser of the sour
apple sniper
but i did i was talking to my daughter
today
and she just did her first
experience on the new
powder yeah the new go powder
and while i was talking to her she was
on the rower
in that c2 getting that pull on pulling
some chain out get that chain out yes
sir and she was saying as she in between
breaths that i wasn't even gonna
row today
but i took to go
it freaking hit
and that is a real thing that's a real
yeah so and i was and i mentioned this
before offline where
i'm no stranger to the jittery
pre-workout powders like i'm i'm i'm not
scared of that kind of stuff and in fact
you get the jitters or whatever all that
stuff
to me that's no factor and in fact when
you're like tired and that jitters hit
you i'd rather have jitters and they'd
be fired up to work out than not have
jitters and not be fired okay right so
i'm like i'm no i'm not i'm not scared
of that kind of stuff right um and are
jitters necessary though that's the
thing that's that seems like we've
discovered that we don't need them i
didn't even think about that stuff to me
that's just what the pre-workout was
good i'll take all of it whatever
whatever
but
it is and i realized this because i
heard people say like oh yeah you drink
this like tea they'd say this about some
teas like yeah you're up but you're but
it's like a smooth or whatever the
smoothness or whatever i'm like cool man
smoothness all good whatever just wasn't
part of my world
until i got the experience
so the pre-workout i took it like cool
the thing is i haven't been doing
pre-workout for like years now
so i took this one i was like cool no
jitters so i'm thinking
maybe jock was just sort of scared of
the pre-workout experience i get it you
know a little bit more mild i get it man
i get it
but when you start warming up that's
when you feel it like that when
everything starts flowing it's like it
connects your brain to your freaking
body more or something that's a body
experience no no in
an in-body experience
what i'm saying is
what your daughter was talking about i
understand yeah and it's true
and yeah i think it reva i i had to
revalu evaluate my whole standard of the
pre-workout because i knew like the
pre-workouts that i was taking that's
not good that's why i stopped yeah
because i'm like cool it's working but
bro i know i'm jamming myself up my
heart i don't know what i'm jumping up
on the inside but i'm jamming something
up
um and yeah man no now i know the new
standard susan so you can get that you
can get your super hard workouts with a
little extra
kick yes sir which might mean you need
to protect yourself from a joint
perspective a little bit more let's go
joint warfare let's go super krill yes
sir might as well might as well keep
your immunity in check because
we're we're starting to work hard
getting like uh uh needing recovery
want maybe the immune system's taking a
little hit we'll get a little boost
from some cold war some vitamin d3
kind of got you covered yeah you know
when you kind of like go down the list
you kind of like it's a whole system
really and it's and it's not the kind of
like uh like i don't want to say useless
because i don't want to like put
put that kind of stigma on other types
of supplements but it's like a whole
system to to stay very solidly like on
the path
and then you get on the because we know
we're kind of in squat season apparently
but then and then you can be in squat
season which means you might want to get
on board the mulk train yes sir
because you're going to need to he build
oh yeah from your activities oh yes
so i
scored
i ate two steaks the other day
concurrently like one in one meal in one
meal two steaks brown rice because
why wouldn't you just have one big steak
uh they were two medium steaks okay i
don't know that's the size you buy at
the store oh yes oh yeah okay i got it
yeah i mean maybe i could have went to
the border you got the butcher yeah you
know and
give me i that didn't happen right how
many ounces were you thinking uh what's
the medium regular one you know you have
the thin one the rib eyes right you have
the thinner eyes okay then you have the
super those super fat ones that you get
from the guy behind the counter and then
you have the regular medium ones okay
you have two of those to the medium
cheers
which was a lot normally and just f1
so i'm like cool i needed some
additional protein that's why i came
home late didn't eat all day i was only
having one meal so i needed to double up
on the protein had to mm-hmm see i'm
saying brown rice but
can't be doing that every day i'm saying
i'm just saying it's not convenient yeah
and also
let's face it when you get done you
still at least i
even with the lost dos rib eyes yeah
i can still get done with two ribeyes
marbled tasty
uh good to go to perfect yeah and you
can still get done i can still get done
and want to have dessert yes sir
what now what am i gonna have for
dessert
could i have something that is negates
my
physical progress i could
or i could just have mulk yeah that's
one more step forward
oh man so good once it hits the lips bro
it's so good thank you jaco for the lips
that's from a movie you should have
picked up on that pick up on that no bro
oh like that is the imagery of your no
that's tips that's uh
frank the tank man in what movie is it
k-dog
old school old school yeah he's talking
about beer like a beer funnel what's it
called a beer funnel is that right beer
beer bong yeah beer bonk it's so good
once it hits the lip that's kind of like
milk it's the same feeling
it's so good once it hits the lip you
just yes sir same thing i understand
fully uh you every uh bison
did i ask you
oh yeah but i think that's the new thing
you get a grass-fed bison ruby smaller
but
it's kind of legit well actually the
thing you know over at other people's
houses right now is actually elk
all right yeah all right that's right
yeah elk is good yeah out there just
you know you you know exactly where it
came from just elkin it up yup all right
good we were there at the moment of
truth yeah did it good good
yes so in the event of you not having
elk in your freezer as the case may be
uh from your hunt as the case may be or
double rib eyes
at any given moment or bison steak right
you want some additional protein monk
train all day
hey you can get all this stuff at
jackalfuel.com if you subscribe to it
the shipping's free you can get the
drinks out
yes sir you can get all of that vitamin
shop
we appreciate those
those stores carrying the stuff because
look you might want to roll in there
yeah
roll in there roll in a wawa get
yourself a hoagie and a go
i didn't really know what a hoagie was
by the way yeah is that an east coast
thing or what yes yes there's a whole
bunch of names for that particular
subway sandwich sub sub sandwich what
you know what we used to call it where
i'm from grinder have you ever heard
that before it would be called
my wife who's from england would call it
a bap
b.a.p
there's some other ones i think we're
missing oh poor boy boy po
that's another one so there's there's
some names out there all right uh yeah
all day meanwhile also
also origin usa this is american-made
stuff look you get look our health is
together we know that already we're
staying on the path it's not don't
complain about staying on the path right
yeah look
you want as far as apparel goes we all
wear clothes hopefully well maybe
we wear clothes we'll say that
let's just say yeah
look we want some uh iconic
american-made attire denim jeans
boots
some shirts mm-hmm some other leather
wallets belts this kind of stuff what if
it was all made in america
oh it is or whatever by the way but you
want that bison steak
cool how about the bison boots
oh yeah made in america leather have you
ever heard me use the term supple before
i think i did one one time and it was
very uncomfortable yeah i'm gonna use it
again right now describing some bison
boots which are
supple all right there you go you heard
it here
but yes but everything made in america
from the from the materials the raw
materials grown in america everything
all the way up to the genes you're
wearing on your
hips and so you're good 24 hours a day
because
you got also because we're training jiu
jitsu you got your jiu-jitsu you've got
a rift key you're going to put you're
never going to get another kind of ghee
again oh yeah so the whole system is
accounted for right here
it's true origin usa.com also jacquez
store so now you want to go into
straight up representing on the path
like
a choice a conscious choice to represent
right is there a
psychological yes sir a hit that you get
when you were a little kid you got new
sneakers yes sir you're running a little
bit faster yes sir where on the path we
put on a freaking t-shirt that says
discipline equals freedom do we go a
little bit harder yes in the pain yes we
do here's the thing that sounds like oh
that's uh that's kind of like funny or
what right it's absolutely true
and here's the thing do an experiment a
scientific example
where is that wear a shirt or hoodie or
whatever says this one equals freedom
look in the mirror and eat a cookie see
how
i'm not saying you're not gonna be able
to eat the cookies i'm not saying that
it's gonna be hard
way harder yes yeah oh yeah so now if
you're just in your everyday life but
you're representing
by the chances of you slipping off the
path even for that moment i actually
feel bad we haven't put this word out
before because this is important
it is kind of important it is yes sir
it's true it's absolutely true so it
just sort of applies like if you're just
representing in general in general it's
just that much more efficient way of
staying on the path that's what i'm
saying and let's face it you see
somebody else representing you're
representing this
the cohesion bro now we're even stronger
together together also
the shirt locker this is a part of
jocko's store it's a part choose a sign
up for short lock you get a new shirt
every month with
did you change the work creative designs
you said something well now they're
actually badass because the new one that
just came out is and it's uh new it's
like a new scenario
it's a tank
[Music]
there's kettlebells flying off which i
noticed yeah you did run into the
kettlebell there's kettlebells like
flying through the air
i'm riding this tank sort of in an
aggressive hostile kind of way wearing a
death core t-shirt t-shirt which i'm
wearing right now by the way maybe i
just dismounted my tank and showed up
here to do this podcast
two machine guns two machine guns um and
the tank is an m1 abrams okay by the way
yeah um so yeah very good the depiction
but it looks like a comic book thing
that's what made it kind of a dope thing
yep it's true i commend your your uh
your work there commended the um
the bad news is
that was last month's shirt or this past
month sure the good news is when you're
signed up for short longer i don't care
if you sign up next year you can still
get that shirt if you want you have
access to that sure if you if you signed
up so
boom no worries anyway yeah
dracostore.com you want to represent
boom that's where you can get the stuff
to represent speaking of subscription
subscribe to this podcast don't forget
about unraveling podcast grounded
podcast warrior kid podcast i got asked
by kids at jocko live which by the way
is jocko live in austin
coming up saturday night yes sir austin
texas
november 20th so you want to come to
that and ask me questions or hang out or
listen to me talk
come check that out but also warrior kid
podcast we also have giaco underground
which
again we we we have contingency plans
we were recently
shadow bands
shadow bands yep we got
on
instagram you know people going why why
did you get shadow back that's the
problem we don't know why we have some
suspicions we're gonna talk about it on
the underground
i'm gonna explain the reasons why i
think the shadow band might have come
i've been on shadow band now apparently
we have
information
we do have information we've got
troopers in in
let's just say
we have place access something we call
access and placement
we have people
so
we will hopefully not let that happen
again but look it can happen
and
that's why we made jocko underground in
case mayhem happens in case
we get locked down we don't control
these platforms that you're listening to
this on we do control jocko
underground.com if you want to help
support us it costs 8 18 cents a month
because we appreciate that support to
have that contingency plan set up we
make an extra podcast jocko underground
we talk about other subjects adjacent to
this
the one that's about to come out is
actually explaining why i think we why i
think i got shadow banned and a little
behind the information
so you can check that out if you want go
to jockowinderground.com if you can't
afford it we still want we we're still
like we're you're still with us
if you can't afford that eight dollars
and 18 cents a month just email
assistance that jockle underground.com
we'll get you access to it we have a
youtube channel
you can subscribe to that or subscribe
to origin usa youtube channel for some
behind the scenes we got an album called
psychological warfare if you need a
little help in a moment of
weakness
and look we could make an album where
you have a moment of weakness and we you
press the track
and it's echo talking about a rubik's
cube for 15 minutes with no
logical meaning behind it that part's
incorrect very much logic yes but we did
we didn't do that maybe we'll do that at
some point people that people that have
more time to overcome their weakness
but if you want to get that koda
wherever you get mp3s you can get
psychological warfare
i am the artist yep because it says
artist's name
yeah yeah so there you go boom flip side
canvas
dakota meyer making just awesome stuff
he started a distribution company by the
way
in in texas i'm investing in his
beverage distribution company he started
going out proactively delivering jocko
go
to various stores and now he's got
people ordering it bro that's an
anti-authoritarianism
there's someone in the way cool i just
outmaneuvered them
oh there's some distribution company
that didn't want to make the connections
oh cool dakota meyer's just in a truck
making it happen
i think he signed up 40 stores right now
my man
hey hey what's going on oh i'll figure
this out make it happen
so there you go he's also got he's also
selling stuff to hang on your wall
flipsidecanvas.com go and order
something cool there
got some books final spin
it's out right now
it's we don't even know what it is novel
poem
we know that it brings tears to j.p
dannell david and l crying in the play
crying in public
um
check that out leadership strategy tax
field manual code evaluation the
protocol displays freedom field manual
way the warrior kid one two three four
get the freaking books for your kids or
kids as you know
it's sort of
if you have the ability to get those
books for some kid that you know and you
don't you are you're not a good person
you're not a good person
if you know a kid and you don't get them
those books you're not you're hurting
those kids this is
a factual yeah so
whatever i know i've met some really
cool people lately i met someone down at
the monster jiu jitsu
player sure he's like oh yeah i carry i
carry way the warrior kid in my bag
any kid that i meet they're getting it
he's just
helping kids worldwide
so
do that
put it in your bag carry it around you
see a kid you go hey kid here you go
imagine that you can influence the rest
of someone's life by doing that
so
way the warrior kid one two three mike
and the dragons
apparently the best uh what age group is
that little kids yeah yeah what do you
call them little kids like post taught i
don't know i don't know what they're
called
level
yeah yep mike and the dragons get your
kids get kids to overcome fear
hackworth about face
um wrote the forward to that what an
honor and then of course extreme
ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership
and uh we have ashland front leadership
consultancy myself and my brother leif
babin
we started that now we got a big bunch
of team a big team of people and what we
do is solve problems through leadership
the solution is leadership
whatever's going on in your organization
the solution is leadership go to
echelonfront.com for details on that
you can also check out some of our live
events the muster field training
exercises
ef battlefield
next musters dallas texas march 24th and
25th
we got jocko live in austin
saturday night
november 20th
come and check it out
we have online training extreme
ownership academy
you do not learn any of this stuff
overnight
you have to train in it just like jiu
jitsu just like playing guitar just like
shooting basketball you need to train
continually go to extremeownership.com
to get your leadership skills honed
and if you want to help service members
active and retired their families gold
star families mark lee's mom
mama lee she's got a charity
organization if you want to donate or
you want to get involved go to america's
mightywarriors.org and if you want more
of my excruciating explanations or you
need more of echo's convoluted
connections to rubik's cubes
well echoes out of controls i am at
jocko willing and to all the troops out
there around the world standing watch
keeping us safe thank you
for your service and sacrifice and to
our police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol secret service
and all first responders
thank you for your service here at home
to keep us safe
and everyone else out there
maybe ask yourself that question if you
are possibly incompetent
and i hope you're not
how do you avoid being incompetent
number one lesson from this book it's
something that we talk about all the
time be humble listen don't think you
know everything
because you don't
be humble keep an open mind
the thing that traps your mind
is your mind
so pry it open
keep it open
and go get after it
and until next time the zekko and jocko
out